[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what up and welcome to the mlb game of
the week pre-game show presented by
fidelity this afternoon fenway park
boston mass red sox and rays finishing
up a three-game series at what is truly
my favorite ballpark in all of the major
leagues we got a half hour to get you
ready for this one is nathan of aldi
against ryan yarbrough as tampa bay is
trying to snap a three-game losing skid
the rays
haven't lost more than three games much
i have to throw this out there hit me
because if any one of us two
is going to be confused of old school it
would be me instead of you correct now
with that said you just said family is
your best ballpark your favorite it was
my favorite experience i have but to due
respect to camden yards i have not been
to oriole park at camden yards yet and
everybody says that is one of their
favorite experiences it is really really
nice but i just thought you'd be the new
and improved kind of guy no i i i like
history bill ripken there's something to
be said and i go back to looking at a
couple of the ballparks i played into
for the first time you still remember it
yankee stadium one yeah fenway the other
one and there are nice ballparks in the
game right now not saying anything about
sure old yankee and fenway but the
history and what you saw
fenway was as close as coming into the
ballpark everything was in black and
white as soon as you came out on that
step of the dug out and you looked at
the field everything was in full color
so it was pretty cool if you have a
chance to get out to a game take the
tour get go around the ballpark it is
amazing by the way bill rick and steven
nelson here in studio 42 in new jersey
rip and
before we get into the match-up today
we're about a week into the season
162 game season not 60. what are your
takeaways knowing that we're watching
things at a different speed last year
through a week we're freaking out
because you know games are three times
as expensive uh for lack of a better
term right
yeah you know what first and foremost
the overall gifts that i had in the
first week there was a little bit of
sloppiness that has gone on i've seen an
awful lot of baseballs being thrown all
over the place and i've always said this
if the ball's there when the big league
play's happening and you see this after
the play's over that's not a good sign
that means something went awry so i
suspect over a little bit of time we'll
clean this up because let's face it i
thought the players did a really good
job last year in that 60-game scenario
yep with no fan in the stands i thought
that they picked the pace up it looked
real
when you were watching the game if you
just honed in on the game and i think no
matter how many fans are in some of
these ballparks or how little amount of
the fans in the ballpark it might be a
little bit of another break-in period
for these fans to be back in their big
league park see scattered fans in the
mix it might be a little bit different
experience more there's definitely more
of a buzz and the folks in boston were
definitely buzzing in game two in case
you missed that action we got some
highlights for you
red sox have just three hits off this
tall ace of the rays tyler glass now and
you see once again slider becoming that
the the go-to
after the fastball the curveball mainly
has been to try to put guys away at the
end of the count it's the eighth
strikeout for tyler glaston
watch his reaction after he gets the out
jd martinez hasn't had many quiet ones
yet but he's over three so far tonight
slaps that one the other way driving
back the right fielder it's over the
head of a rosarina
berdugo rounding third and he is in to
slide and score
another extra base hit from martinez
it's a one-run game
three to two raise christian and this
one is grounded out to third walked and
struck out
high fly ball
that one way back there watch it go
it is gone
and this game is tied
oh he got all of it
and a red sox tying 3-3 in the night and
so the winning run is at third and they
are not going to intentionally walk at
least to start jd martinez he's got a
chance to win it
shot oh terrific play there throw on to
first base and in time
on a diving effort by adonis
runner at second base is brandon loud a
face willie adams one of the heroes of
the 10th
and that's a liner up the left side back
toward the corner that's going to score
the round extra bases for a diamonds and
the reigns will take the lead here in
the 11th inning
rafael devers will leave things up
sander bogarts made the last out the
10th inning will be placed at second
base as the runner
and a liner and a basin into left field
giving chase
and here comes xander he is in to score
and this game is tied again
now the winning run is on base in
verdugo and now a single could win the
game
that one's driven to right field rosa
rania backing up back it up it's over
his head it's over his head and the red
sox are going to win the game two-run
score
boston wins
boy is that a fitting end to this one
wow the red sox win it
six to five
what a ball game this was
five sox win and rip they scored 17 runs
these two games against tampa after what
five in the first three games against
after three side young award winners of
baltimore went in there and that's right
shut them down look jd is hot right here
nobody else has necessarily gotten it
going i think
the names on the backs and some of the
flip sides of the baseball cards
statistically these guys are going to be
fine they got some pretty good offensive
players no question about it endeavors
interests me a lot because i think it
might get him going let's take a look at
what happened last night when he tied
this thing up and i'm going to talk a
little bit about staying on the baseball
how to stay on it we've heard this
phrase go an awful lot of time but this
is kind of what it is right there ball
right down broadway at 92 he smacks the
line drive to tie the game to left field
this is a really nice swing look at that
front shoulder the longer the front
shoulder stays closed
that's how you stay on the baseball this
guy's been doing it this is his game
winner right there even though that's 78
is a little bit slower speed of a pitch
and it's on inner third it's a breaking
ball
sweeping away from jd and he stays
closed long enough and when i want to
talk about that when staying closed and
how it works because we look at video we
break things down on every frame and
there are some times where people may
think that this thing gets out here
because it gets to the baseball and
launches it both of those were opposite
field devers went that way hidden out of
that box jd goes that way as well as
anybody in the game and yes there will
be a time when this thing goes so you
can get to it but if this thing leaks
early if i do this pretty much the only
pitch i can handle is the ball middle in
and mostly you get the head out and you
hit it this way with jd this ball was
kind of inner
third ish it was almost middle but it
was more on this side but like i said
the breaking ball is going away and if
his approach is thinking i'm going to
hit the pitcher right in his bean with
the line drive yeah this thing will stay
closed a little bit longer and when that
stays closed instead of doing this and
maybe having the bad head drop and you
had a fly ball over there you stay
closed and you get to that point where
the bat head can get to it a little bit
more direct then he hits the ball lower
in that direction can i ask you a
question yes sir so we may have a lot of
fans among the more than two million
subscribed to the mlb youtube channel
watching the pregame show right now
young ball players and is there a drill
that you found to help
stay on top of the baseball well one
thing i like an awful lot i like the
soft toss from the front i do it in here
a lot in fact if you can go look through
the youtube channel you'll see sean
casey hitting me right in the lips when
i'm sitting out there in this network
the ball away okay a hitter must do more
right in order to hit that
i can cheat and do things wrong
mechanically and still have some success
in here but in order to hit this ball on
the outer part of the plate you have to
be more direct with the bad head to the
ball so i would say the best drill to
stay on the ball forces you to stay
closed is soft toss from the front and
let's toss it out here on the inner
third don't try to trick them yep don't
mix them up especially if it's a young
kid toss the ball out here and say hit
the screen hit me in the face use a
screen because i was using a plastic
ball so i had to get away with that one
yeah but to hit the ball back up the
middle and and i can tell you this
i remember being on the phone with my
father in 1986 in double a i'd call him
i'd say dude i had a couple pitches
right down in the middle eight fly balls
to right field i should hit those ball
better he said do me a favor son
tomorrow during batting practice think
about one thing hit line drives back up
the middle so what he was he was
diagnosing without seeing video phone
call my front shoulder was probably
leaking and then i'd have a ball down
the middle i didn't fly ball to right so
he says go out there and take batting
practice hit the ball back up the middle
try to hit the guy throwing bp in the l
screen just keep hitting the ball back
up the middle when the game starts
all thoughts out of your head go hit the
ball hard a couple times for me tomorrow
love it don't don't get a hit
go hit the ball hard a couple times
report back usually that fixed the
problem because if that thing leaks
anything middle away i'm probably going
to hit a weak fly ball to write rip
learning you some stuff here in studio
42. so we're getting closer and closer
to the first pitch at fenway red sox and
rays and will be game of the week live
on youtube
we want you to get involved right now
okay
we're going to put up this poll who is
going to win today
tampa bay or boston yarborough and baldy
ray's trying to snap a three-game skit
you let us know and they will be game of
the week presented by fidelity pre-game
poll
fenway park sun is shining much better
than opening day a week ago it was
raining delayed the game postponed the
game against the orioles they're
definitely playing
boston today 12 30 first pitch scott
braun john smalls carlos pena and alana
rizzo on the call
[Applause]
he'll go after that one and drive that
one high it's deep to left and that
ball's gone well there's number two he
didn't wait very long
don't you think the red sox have to make
sure he's in the lineup every day
that ball is hammered that's a high fly
ball twisting deep deep deep gone
berdugo strikes again
well that's the way to add on and get
some wiggle room deeper than the first
one also to the opposite field
this is a high fly ball driven deep to
right
rodu go back to the pen
leaps up he caught it
he caught the ball he took it back
tonight what a night
here's the pitch and a swing of the
drive down the right fia line deep back
it goes and it is gone opposite field
home run bobby dalback he's homered now
in five straight games that ties a red
sox record he didn't get it all but he's
so strong it jumped that one's driven to
right field rosa rania backing up back
it up it's over his head it's over his
head and the red sox are gonna win the
game
two runs score
boston wins red sex win it six to five
and that celebration goes all the way
down the third base line
in case you all forgot you're watching
the mlb game of the week pregame show
presented by fidelity
[Music]
let's turn on that creator spotlight
on giraffe neck mark if you know
baseball and you know youtube you know
baseball on youtube then he needs no
introduction but i'm gonna give it to
you in case you're uninitiated draftneck
mark the name of his channel is getting
close to 200 000 subscribers on youtube
so he's got opinionated but also
informative videos about everything
going on in major league baseball
jerseys stadiums season predictions
rankings reactions to what's going on
and much much more and his favorite team
the new york mets he is not alone trust
me in this building there are a lot of
mets fans let's say hi to mark now he's
joining us for the pre-game show mark
great to visit with you finally on this
mlb game of the week youtube on youtube
pregame show first and foremost give me
the genesis of your channel and your
story
yes so i'm a huge baseball fan and
growing up baseball was a huge part of
my life played it pretty much every
single summer every single day so when i
went to college and the baseball career
was kind of over i needed to find a way
to continue that passion for baseball
and youtube was the perfect way for me
to do that so just started making videos
people started watching it and now it's
turned into my job every single day so i
couldn't ask for a better story and a
better job really and then how did you
fall in love with the new york mets
yeah i got to give a shout out to my dad
there he's a huge mets fan and from the
day i was born till today i mean we've
been watching mets baseball together so
it really comes from my dad but i mean
the mets how can you not love this team
they're the best especially this year
there's so much buzz and excitement but
you're not a bandwagoner you you've seen
some things as a mets fan as they say
what were the best things that you see
your favorite moments
yeah i mean one of the first mets
moments i can remember is when todd
pratt hit the home run in the you know
postseason i was about three or four
years old at the time i don't remember
my exact age but i was really young and
i remember my dad his phone number was
917 and i called 911 about five or six
times trying to call him that todd pratt
hit this home run police ended up coming
to my grandparents house and i mean
that's such a great memory for me
because the mets win and i also got a
great story with the police coming to
think that something was wrong
that's incredible all right do you want
to talk about this game today we got in
boston
red sox and rays yeah no this this is a
great game i'm super excited to talk
about this one so i watched one of your
videos pre-season and your prediction
show or your friction and video that
should be the red sox were 16th i want
to say on that list and the rays were
10th we're still not yet a week old in
this season but i'm going to give you
opportunity do you want to change those
rankings at all are you going to stay
with it
no i usually stay pretty true to my
predictions and rankings even if some
stuff changes during the season but i
mean both these teams are really good i
think we've seen a lot of good stuff
from the red sox the last few games and
the rays you just can't ever doubt them
they're just a really fun team to watch
yeah and so how do you forecast the
division race as a whole beyond just
these two teams
yeah i mean it pains me to say it but i
think the yankees are probably the best
in that division i got them winning the
ale as a mets fan it really it really
hurts me but the yankees and such a deep
division with the blue jays and race too
but the yankees are the favorites for
sure baltimore has made some noise here
at the start are you buying it or are
you selling it
i am buying into their hype they've got
a lot of stuff going on especially on
the pitching side they brought some guys
in from the astros and we know how good
they are with their pitching department
and you can see it with some of their
arms with bruce zimmerman john means
they've made a lot of steps forward this
year so i'm buying into the orioles hype
100 so people watch giraffe neck mark on
youtube they know that they're going to
get some uniform some swag
videos as well and it was announced
earlier this week that the red sox nike
city connect jerseys were unveiled what
they're going to be wearing on patriots
day against the chicago white sox
and a lot of folks were talking about
them what do you think
i think they are so awesome i'm always
for teams across mlb getting new
different jerseys and even though yellow
and light blue isn't typically the
colorway that you see with the red sox i
absolutely love the design i'm gonna go
buy a jersey of mine for myself love it
give us your top five players to watch
in baseball right now
such a good list but i think we have to
start it off of course with the best
player in baseball possibly the best
player of all time mike trout he's just
so good fernando tatis arguably the face
of baseball he's incredible as well you
know running hitting throwing fielding
he's just you got to watch him at all
times gotta give a shout to shohei otani
too who's a teammate of trouts and the
stuff that he does we've never seen in
the history of baseball pitching hitting
throwing 100 miles an hour hitting it
450 feet he's just like possibly the
most talented player we've ever seen
juan soto with the nationals another one
that hurts me a little bit too as a mets
fan but he's just so good and he's like
only 22 23 years old and he's incredibly
talented through the roof and of course
gotta give a shout out to my own
favorite team the new york mets and
jacob degrom the best pitcher in
baseball hands down don't want to hear
anything else he's so good every time
he's on the mound he has a chance to do
something special you've got to watch
that guy pitch well let's keep it with
that met's theme one more time because
jacob degrom i think if you ask anybody
any pitcher in the game they're saying
he's the best man walking the planet
right now
but it's francisco lindor who has
everybody lit up in and around flushing
queens because of his massive extension
how happy are you this seems like an
easy question how happy are you that
he's gonna be around for a decade plus
you can probably see the smile on my
face i haven't been able to wipe it off
since we traded for him and then once
they extended him i mean the smile has
gone nowhere mr smile's his nickname
it's translated to me as well i cannot
be happier with signing this guy he's
going to be here for the next 11 years
this is where he's probably going to end
his career i'm through the roof excited
and he's one of those players that i
think he's that six tool star we talk
about the five tools on the field he's
got that sixth one off of it just so
electric so magnetic i would say not
just to mets fans or cleveland fans but
anybody who loves baseball and loves
pure joy they love francisco lendore and
maybe he's the answer to this next
question if there was one player in the
game that you would want to have join
your ranks as a youtube creator who
would it be
yeah you hit the nail right in the head
it's going to be francisco lindor he has
so much charisma so much personality and
i think with this new york team we're
really going to see that shine
especially because he is in a big market
now with new york but i'd love to see
him just grab a camera vlog being in the
clubhouse what he's doing before the
game hanging around with pete alonso
jacob degrom jeff mcneil dom smith like
this team is so much fun and i can't
wait to see the kind of you know
excitement that he also brings along
with the rest of the guys i'm not going
to talk to giraffe neck mark and not get
a prediction we got a game coming up
here red sox raise who you got today
you know what i'm gonna go with the red
sox on this one uh got a lot of red sox
fans who watch me and they've been
playing good baseball recently as good
as the rays are i'm gonna go with the
home team today in the boston red sox
giraffe neck mark subscribe to the
channel like the videos leave some
comments interact with them he's all
over social media and loves chopping up
with baseball fans and we love chopping
it up with him thanks so much mark
thanks for having me on guys appreciate
it
thank you speaking of picks picks to
click john smoltz is going to make them
next
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the swings against the fastball get
better and better for brussels 3-2
brasso sends one into left field gardner
going back and it is up and gone
mike rosso has homered
and the rays have a two to one lead what
a moment for brusso
here is a shot into right center field
this ball is back at the wall and he's
got another
and the all-time record for home runs in
a single post season with number nine
that ball was tattooed
jansen a strike away
the one-two pitch
and phillips has cashed in a base hit
back up the middle here's carefire to
score the ball's mishandled
[Applause]
[Music]
back toward the corner that's going to
score the round extra bases for adamus
and the reyes will take the lead here in
the 11th inning and he picks up a big
rbi double to give the raise a 4-3 lead
maybe the game-winner if the race can
hold
this is the mlb game of the week pregame
show presented by fidelity
with john smoltz he's calling the game
with scott braun carlos pena and alana
rizzo smultzy first of all good to see
you yeah good to be back second question
did you have a favorite youtube video i
know you're always on the internet
preparing for games unfortunately it
revolves around me and it revolves
around the stadium they're playing today
at fenway i basically in a small box as
you know there got hit in the wrong
place on a foul ball as an announcement
from
the wrong place yeah gotcha yeah it was
bad you had bad red sox memories he
showed up at spring training they didn't
know who he was down in florida but
despite that he's going to be objective
in calling this game so red sox raise an
interesting pitching match yeah right
vivaldi yarbrough different stuff
different sides what do you make of it
yeah it's like opposites right you got a
hard throwing stuffed guy and avaldi
who's going to light up the radar gun
and then you've got yarborough who's
basically going to do the opposite spin
it deceive it soft contact so you're
going to see a basic difference between
how two guys get it done one left hand
and one right hand nathan naval of
course he's going to dial it up and
yarbrough the last couple seasons been
the best at limiting hard contact in
terms of average exit velocity against
while we're here with you smallest we're
going to play a game it's time for picks
to click presented by bet mgm i'm going
to pepper you with some questions you
just hit me with your answer i know
we're so young in the season but don't
marry yourself to these okay
yankees came into the year as the
favorite for the division currently
behind the orioles in the standings
who's going to challenge them who's
going to be their biggest competitor
well the easy answer would be the raise
because of what they did last year but i
think it's actually going to be somebody
that rhymes with raise and it's going to
be j's i think toronto has done enough
if they stay healthy they feel like they
can compete in the division and give the
yankees probably a challenge that
you know might go throughout most of the
year
toronto blue jays of course hoping that
their starting rotation can be healthy
beyond human rieu now let's talk about a
guy we're going to see today jd martinez
off to a really nice start after a
brutal 2020 just seven home runs after
what
79 the two seasons combined prior
over under 32 and a half dingers for jd
in 2021 i think that's a great number
but i don't think last year represents
what kind of hitter he is i think he's
going to get really close it's a great
number i'm going to take a little bit of
the over on that because
jd martinez is a professional hitter and
what have you done for me lately society
and baseball don't get caught up in that
this guy knows how to hit the offense is
balanced he's going to get pitched to a
lot he's going to play a lot and i think
the numbers will show up this year and
he's one of those guys who talked about
the lack of video last year and how that
really hurt him it's back this year he
feels much more comfortable at the plate
i imagine that's could be said for a lot
of players listen right wrong and
different mentally is the biggest thing
that if you feel it and believe it
that's all that matters it doesn't
matter what the numbers say but if
you're on the other side of that and you
really struggle and get out of your
comfort zone it can affect you and it
did last year for him just seven home
runs last year as i mentioned two
already this year in five games seven
extra base hits and nine ribbies on the
other side the postseason darling for
the tampa bay rays randy arose arena he
was a cs mvp and he's now eligible to
win rookie of the year so
would you call him your favorite in the
american league i would call him
everybody's favorite but i think that's
a little bit of too strong to just think
that because you're the favorite that
he's going to roll in and just
absolutely leave
pick up where he left off i think
there's going to be a total different
pitch selection to him this year i'm not
saying he's going to struggle but i
don't think he's going to win rookie of
the year just based on all the talk
about what he did in that unbelievable
post season i wish i wish it would it
would carry over like that it doesn't
always carry over like that right that's
a bar that just said way too high for
anybody like due respect to randy like
just anybody who puts up 10 home runs
and 90 something maybes in the
postseason now you got a lot of eyeballs
on you but you're right they tried to
sneak fast behind him last year and he'd
crush them now let's get into your
wheelhouse the pitching side if you were
to forecast the cy young award in the
american league since we've got two al
teams today who got the front
it's hard to go against the yankees and
garrett cole
i think he's got his adjustment period
in he's obviously a fantastic pitcher
and he's going to benefit from that
offense for 162 games so it's not a big
limb i'm jumping out on but i think
garrett cole it's his to lose and i hate
saying that because i've been on the
other side of that when somebody said
that about me yeah but i think he's that
good and the yankees offense will be
that good that it's it's it's his well
we see some of the odds presented by
that mgm shane beamer the reigning scion
award winner lucas g little tyler glass
now now that he's got a third pitch yeah
what would you say the the the biggest
challenger that you love the most after
cole would be well the reason you you
know you mentioned glasnow and i think
the fact that he has went through last
year
and he has added that third pitch is
going to be a weapon um
it's going to come down to does he pitch
enough
innings in this year i think that's
going to be a bigger priority this year
that has been in the past because you
could have a huge gap between pitchers
yep and that's the weird shane bieber i
mean
he's going to pitch innings he's going
to strike out a lot of guys it's a great
race in the american league from the
power arms so i i would say glass now is
a nice sneaky pick because of his odds
yeah and i don't know if fans realized
that everything he's done up to this
point he's just was done with two
pitches and hitters could sell out he's
like they can't do that anymore he's
keeping him honest with that third
weapon okay
now i think if someone were to ask you
your favorite picture in the game right
now uh am i safe to say it's jacob
degrom yes okay so let's talk about
degrom in the national league
wins are what's hard to come by for
jacob degrom at least that's what we've
seen
in his tenure with the new york mets
over under 15 and a half another great
number and it would be easy to buy into
the narrative of what he's done the last
two years and what he hasn't done in the
win category
wipe that from your mind he's going to
win over 15 games this year i know the
first game didn't go
the way it was supposed to but you're
talking about a totally revamped
offensive team for the new york mets and
jacob degrom keeps getting better and
better here's the guy that knows how to
pitch with not only multiple pitches but
whether he's on or not that's a big part
of being an elite pitcher and i think
jacob the ground will finally break
through in the win column i'm going to
go out and say something like 17-3 wow
or maybe even
and four somewhere in that category
because
there's just no way it can continue
there's no way
it can continue and i think as time
builds up
you won't see the early exits to protect
for the whole season and as time builds
up you're going to see that offense
finally give way of whatever look
if you're pitching against jacob degrom
you're going to pitch your best game
because you have to that's part of the
issue so the offense does gets a lot of
blame sometimes of the bullpen the
pressure is mounting because everyone's
talking about the same thing every time
he pitches i mean because since 2018 his
era is 207 and in the games that he's
pitched the mets record is 36 and 41.
cannot continue i mean mets fans are
like yeah you would think that but it
keeps happening to them 17 wins that's
that's i would say that's a bold
prediction yeah but i like it john
smoltz you're going to hear him plenty
today on the call with scott brown
carlos pena and alana rizzo thank you
you got it
and thank you everybody who participated
in the mlb game of the week poll who's
going to win today tampa bay or boston
55 of you going with the red sox to
sweep the rays bill ripton what do you
think of that it looks like a lot of
northeast northeasterners voted right
there so you know what these are two
pretty good teams and i think at the end
of the day i think the rays are going to
be there once again when we start
talking about playoff teams down the
stretch the red sox are going to go as
far as i think the big three and that's
bogart's devers and jd martinez if you
hit those guys in order you might have
some order first pitch coming your way
scotty b's got you
here's the pitch
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
signs of spring this week with
temperatures rising in the northeast
stress levels ran high yesterday with
the red sox mounting three late
comebacks and walking off as winners in
extras now back at it 14 hours later for
a global audience this is the mlb game
of the week live on youtube presented by
fidelity in massachusetts the tampa bay
rays meet up with the boston red sox to
put a lid on this three-game series at
fenway park with boston going for the
sweep of the defending a.l champs i'm
scott braun along with the hall of famer
john smoltz we're bringing you the
action from studio k and hello to the
youtube audience around the globe for
our first journey on youtube in 2021 and
john we like to have representatives
from both teams and
some might not know long time brave but
a little sliver with the boston red sox
there might be people scratching their
heads going what's small's doing on this
broadcast yeah i was able to get with
the historic organization after my
shoulder surgery if i could have a redo
i'd like to go back and perform a little
better than i did we could talk about it
or not whatever you want as we introduce
the youtube audience to the mlb game of
the week things to know we are streaming
live this is global on mlb's youtube
channel and it's all free tell your
friends join the over 2.7 million other
fans in subscribing to mlb's youtube
channel you can click the bell icon for
notifications prior to upcoming games
and if you have youtube tv like i do
game stream live and an mlb pop-up
within the channel guide we have more
friends as well carlos pena represents
the tampa bay rays long time ray you
also played for boston grew up in boston
went to northeastern you really know
both teams well carlos how you doing
today
i'm doing very well excited to be with
you guys and yes i guess i am the
perfect guy for this situation because i
know boston like the palm of my hand and
at the same time i also play for the
race and i'm very proud to say so
experience that uh 2008 world series
with them uh so i'm really excited to uh
get on with this ball game and a cape
cod league mvp i mean the list of
accomplishments with the rays and the
red sox we have time we'll run through
it but let's run through this pitching
match up with ryan yarbrough matching up
against nate ibaldi and
smolty i think you could call these two
very different pitchers which is always
fun to get a variety of plates
absolutely you couldn't be more opposite
than what these guys not to mention
they're throwing with a different hand
an arm but they do it differently and
yarbrough is going to mix and match spin
have soft contact as his friend and the
baldi's going to have the
radar gun light it up and use his stuff
to power through that lineup so when you
think about these two pitchers you've
got to think totally opposite of what
they're trying to accomplish the red sox
of course need pitchers they need to be
healthy we know what the rays have been
able to do as a pitching staff they can
mix and match with anybody but evaldi
start today is going to be super
important i know it's early but as they
build their resume as a starting staff
and get healthy
pitching is what's going to keep them in
this year and he's coming off a good one
on opening day against the orioles
yarbrough was great last week in his
first start as well the problem for
ivaldi i would say carlos he's going to
circle the lineup in the spot where
randy or rosarena is and say
how do i pitch this guy
he was incredible in the playoffs last
year what did you think
you know he really was impressive you
know his approach was pristine he
started from the top of the strike zone
down
and that really really helped him but he
saw everything scotty they threw him
fastballs but mostly off speed if you
can believe it look at the regular
season post season split
he had a very good overall season but
that postseason was absolutely monstrous
i mean those are record-setting numbers
as you see right there with the 10 home
runs uh in the postseason postseason
that is a record but this is the thing
he was the only one that
really performed offensively and maybe
this is perhaps why the
race could not win that world series if
he would have gotten just a little bit
of help maybe we would be telling a
different story and he would have a ring
on his finger but here they go again and
they're going to give it another world
and randy rosarina coming with very high
expectations and it's crazy but he's
actually still rookie eligible even
though he played more in the playoffs
last year than he did in the regular
season so experience on the boston side
is actually probably more than you think
according to alex cora you said hey we
have players that have world series
rings and players with proven track
records especially at the plate well
they do and their offense shouldn't take
a back seat last year was not a great
year for the red sox for a lot of
reasons their pitching got hurt and they
couldn't score enough runs but they have
a stable offense that suits their
ballpark well and xander boldheart said
we're talking about shortstops all
throughout baseball he gets under look
he had a big contract extension he
really is the heart and soul of that uh
middle infield and then jd martinez what
can you say about him he's a
professional hitter he's a pitchers
nightmare last year was an outlier don't
even pay attention to what happened last
year a lot of things changed for a lot
of players and look for him to have a
monster year again for the red sox
offensively they're going to be
competitive it's whether or not they can
keep the
arms on the mound healthy to complement
this offense it's not too early to say
that offensively these last three games
have been huge they needed to get off to
a good start they didn't but they
rallied and they're in a position now to
utilize that offense and be a strength
it was a top five team in terms of
offense in the american league last year
but it was a last place team in the al
east but alex cora told us earlier jd
martinez is back he said he was never
gone and for more on jd let's welcome in
the fourth member of our team alana
rizzo who is stationed at fenway park
alana scotty red sox slugger jd martinez
has been incredibly vocal about his
preference to be able to use video in
game to make those in-game offensive
adjustments well in 2020 that routine of
his was disrupted when mlb disallowed
video rooms as well as video in the
dugout to try to promote social
distancing also making sure that they're
coming off of the heels of that 2017
investigation into the world series well
in 2021 the video is back on league
issued ipads and already making
dividends for j.d martinez so far this
season 10 for 21 two home runs and five
doubles that leads the league in last
night that two out two run double
security series win a chance for the
sweep and guys since joining the red sox
you can see
that last season was absolutely an
anomaly you can see all of the offensive
categories that people talk about all
down in the 2020 year jd martinez
certainly liking the video back in the
dugout back in the video rooms not only
for himself scotty but to help his
teammates as well
thanks alana he's been saying just show
me the video and he's right it's the
runner-up from last season in visiting
the 18 champs for a wednesday afternoon
matchup on youtube lineups and first
pitch on the way
these two teams hate each other
there has been some bean balls here in
this series these two teams go at it
here we go again that's what makes this
a great rivalry
[Applause]
up and in and that hit him
uh that may have been intentional
that is about the fifth or sixth guy hit
by a pitch in this series annie has the
ball thrown behind him well let's hope
that's the end of the uh funny stuff now
swinging a drive you brush him back
he'll hit it out
look out over his head with a breaking
ball and ortiz is going out towards the
mount shields hits crisp and no goal is
going to head out
here we
go
look out and ortiz gets hit in the back
it's a war
you know it's on that was absolutely
an in-your-face move
this rivalry is player against player
organization against organization and to
me that's true rivalry
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a cloudy day in boston
massachusetts temperatures in the 50s
for the rays and the red sox wrapping up
their first series of this season
against each other and let's introduce
you to the starting lineup presented by
fidelity yoshi suzugo will lead the way
for tampa bay followed by austin meadows
looking for a bounce back season the
legend from last october randy rosarena
in the three spot brandon lau cleaning
up yandi diaz the dh this afternoon joey
wendell with excellent career numbers
against nate ivaldi in a small sample
size he's five for seven then it's
margot mejia and adamus to round out the
nine
[Music]
so the first start of the season for
native aldi featured temperatures in the
low 30s about a 20 degree bump this
afternoon how does that help
that's going to help a lot with the feel
even though he's a power pitcher you got
to have that secondary stuff working and
look this guy is so important to the red
sox as they try to get some of their
other guys healthy
and he's just go get him he throws a lot
of strikes early he's
a guy that can light up the radar gun
but unfortunately at times if he's not
ahead in the count the hitters have had
a huge advantage against them so far
behind in the count so vivaldi
gonna do what he does and he's a kind of
a nolan ryan throwback and uh that's
what you're gonna see out of him today
today
funny you mentioned that name because
he's from alvin texas just like nolan
ryan
nate grew up idolizing the great nolan
ryan and let's set up the infidelity
defense for the boston red sox bobby
dolphin is back at first base after a
couple days off christian arroyo next to
him and your usual devers and bogarts on
the left side of the infield involved
playing catch with kevin plowecki this
afternoon and outfield from left to
right jd martinez hernandez and hunter
renfro just the
first start of the season in left field
for jd and he made three starts all of
last year in left so he'll get some run
on the other side of the baseball
that's a different outfield scotty i
mean this is uh where you see kiki
hernandez playing center field he's
going to be playing all over the place
as well as marvin gonzalez it adds a lot
of versatility for the red sox to have
those guys on board
yeah there's [ __ ] in center he's been
playing a lot of second base so far this
season and marwin's been playing
everywhere already and he says he's used
to that he's actually more comfortable
playing in different spots on different
occasions
eval do you set first pitch of the
season delivered live on youtube as
we're ready to go for the raise and the
red sox
misses outside to yoshi susugo
who has been inserted into the lead-off
spot this year to try and ignite his bat
goes around it's one and one
carlos he had trouble handling high
velocity last year coming over from
japan signing a two-year contract with
tampa bay looking to get himself
acclimated pulls the 1-1 down the line
nice play by dahl back to the covering
ivaldi for out number one
and right there it's something that he
needs to make an adjustment with us to
get ready early enough to get you that
high speed fastball at the top of the
zone ray is sort of a cutter that crowds
him but he was able to get good barrel
and just a better play here in dalmart's
hand
doll back a natural third baseman
he's been picking up the position over
at first very quickly he said it's a
footwork adjustment but he looks like a
natural there
now it's austin meadows
health setbacks last year but an
all-star in 2019
he hit 33 home runs a couple years ago
with 89 rbis
last year just four in the shortened
season
a lot of this offense predicated on the
long ball of course and
they feel like they've got the same
basic offense they had last year even
though they struggled on the stretch in
the postseason
a lot of that would be contributed to
great pitching
speaking of that pitching let's get the
breakdown from you smolty presented by
fidelity yeah i think for a baldy it's
going to be key to establish obviously
is fastball to get ahead of the count
but it's controlled the right-handed
hitters he had some struggles against
right-handed hitters in the past pitch
ahead because when he's behind the
numbers are really not good and give the
red sox some innings
popped up
and here comes devers in foul ground for
out number two
i mean you think about a guy that throws
this hard when he's behind in the count
over the last uh until 2019 hitting
against him 449 when he's behind in the
count so every pitcher wants to go
strike one
as they say but to be able to pitch with
his stuff and get hitters off his hard
fastball because the cutter fastball
combination even though it has high
velocity he's given up a higher average
than he should with that with that pitch
here's the matchup with the rosarina
he takes the first pitch on the inside
corner
alex cora mentioned to us that the rays
faced native aldi in spring training and
they ambushed him on first pitch so alex
thinks it was actually a good learning
experience for nate
for this regular season matchup in on
the hands a little blooper foul
well spring training you get if you're a
veteran pitcher you could play a kind of
mind tricks with the other team and
especially with the no travel this year
they got to face each other and i
guarantee you what i would have done is
thrown completely different than i was
going to throw knowing my matchups in
the regular season and just get them
scratching their head a little bit and
then the vice in the reverse obviously
what you talked about he could util
utilize some of that information in
spring training and go okay
all right i'll make the adjustment
so far so good and he's ahead of a rose
arena
look at the defense a lot of space up
the middle
they just missed
and you can see him working right here
just with the high fastball and then the
off speed and you see a rosarito has
been actually late on some of those
fastballs and that's really baldy one
wants to keep him in between as far as
his timing is concerned
goes with the slower stuff to get an
easy roller
and sit down the side in order a one two
three first from ivaldi we'll see the
red sox fat in the bottom of the first
red sox have a bunch of guys who are due
and here's one of them hunter renfro
he's over eight
and a one-o
hammered the other way
long dive on what a play by rosarina a
spectacular play
vasquez will tag and he is in to score
i don't know if you're going to see a
better play by an outfielder
all season long
i mean this ball looked like it was
going to go over his head he jumps dives
catches it walker delivers swing a drive
to right center feel it well a rose
arena going back still going back this
one is over his head it hits off the
bullpen wall he dives to stop it in the
third jd being waved home here comes the
throw to the plate by obama's it's off
the glove of the first baseman too late
throw the third goes down the left field
line and zander will score
the red sox get two and lead at five
nothing
went after that one off the outside
corner down the line that one's sailing
and it is gone
into the pesky pole
a three-run homer for jd martinez
and the socks really blow it open here
in the 8th inning
a clean first from navy now ryan
yarber's turn against this starting
lineup for the red sox presented by
fidelity [ __ ] hernandez out in center
this afternoon he's leading off the
endeavors jd is on fire right now to
start the season bogart's cleaning up
christian vazquez the vh this afternoon
renfro arroyo dalbec back in the lineup
and plowecki the catcher
here's the pitcher very different look
left-hander ryan yarborough and they
call it contact suppression his
specialty yeah he's got a great
deception to his delivery and he creates
an illusion to the hitter that the ball
is going to get there and it doesn't so
he relies a lot on spin and a lot of
change of direction of the baseball and
i'll tell you what i know he's been
viewed as a reliever statistically but
he's a starter they've used him out of
the bullpen after an opener or whatever
you want to call it but now i think he's
going to provide a lot of innings as a
starter and a number two starter
first pitch to [ __ ] hernandez misses
wide
coming off an excellent opening
performance against the marlins five and
two-thirds shutout innings just 65
pitches not a long leash but that's
tampa based style
and he finds the zone against hernandez
carlos also ryan yarborough grew up in
lakeland florida a huge tampa bay rays
fan a carlos pena fan he loves that 2008
squad
how about that i mean this is great when
you see guys that have grown up
just rooting for a ball club and then
they have an opportunity to put on that
jersey it's literally a dream come true
and yarbor is one of those guys that
does not take it for granted and you
hear him talk about his style of
pitching and he doesn't care that he's
different than those
epic lefties that the race had he has a
different style which is just pitch to
contact and make sure he induces weak
contact at
that there's your weak contact
and adamus puts away hernandez
more on that weak contact
pitching looks like ryan yarborough
here's a breakdown presented by fidelity
yeah soft contact that's a word a lot of
pitchers like to hear because that puts
your defense in play and it gets them to
do what they can do and that's play
great defense deception and spin we
already saw it in the first hitter and
then pitched like a starter i mentioned
all the innings he gets as a reliever
after someone else has started the game
but i think this guy is going to be a
throwback guy in an era of velocity he
knows how to pitch he knows how to
change arm angles and
the quadrants of the strike zone
he finds the zone against rafael devers
who picked up his first two hits of the
season yesterday
recording a two for five performance
24 years old in his fourth season
already is deborah's the third baseman
awaits the 0-1
i mean he's pretty much going to con
go after right-handers with a lot of
change-ups and left-handers that do face
him in the lineup he'll give him more
fastballs because he gives the illusion
that that 88 is really 96 and 95 because
of the change of tempo and to me about
pitching is changing the timing of a
hitter and creating some fear that the
hitter can't just jump out and lay into
one of those pitches so hitter's got to
have
a lot of different thoughts in his head
when this guy's on the mound
two quick strikes
and ever stays alive
this is a very dynamic uh
confrontation because devos has been
known uh for his exit velocity you know
fifth uh among hitters in the american
league in 2020 93 miles per hour off of
his back that's what he averaged and
yarbor is one of those guys who tries to
do the opposite which is induce weak
contact so very interesting
match-up we got going today
garbero likes to take advantage of over
aggressive hitters
feasts on long swings
and evers goes fishing
it's just a really good example of you
don't have to just fire the baseball and
let your stuff take care of hitters see
that arm angle and that release point i
guarantee you devers thought that ball
was in the strike zone a lot longer than
it was and that's why when you're
sitting at home going how can it hit her
swing at that pitch and look that bad
it's because when he look at the tunnel
of where that ball's coming out of the
pitcher's hand
it looks like a strike and obviously we
could see the results were nowhere close
good luck though and you got that kind
of angle that you're trying to hit
off luck to yarbrough against shady
martinez first pitch swinging going the
other way we'll see if it's playable for
a rosarena in right field
and he's got it in his glove
is made right next to the fans great to
have fans back
for 2021 randy arose arena unfazed
what a play
that's a tough corner right there for
fenway park
hey watch out
about six people going for that ball and
the right man for the race came up with
it
that sacks have just three hits off this
tall ace of the raised
look glass now and you see once again
slider becoming that the go-to
after the fastball the curveball mainly
has been to try to put guys away at the
end of the count it's the eighth
strikeout for tyler glassman
swing and a miss he
struck him out watch his reaction after
he gets the out
christian and this one is grounded out
to third walked and struck out
high fly ball
that one way back there watch it go
it is gone
and this game is tied
the winning run is on base in verdugo
and now a single could win the game
that one's driven to right field rosania
backing up back it up it's over his head
it's over his head and the red sox are
going to win the game
two-run score
boston wins
boy is that a fitting end to this one
wow the red sox win it six to five
what a ball game this one
[Music]
[Music]
back at fenway park and the last catch
or maybe catch from randy rosarina is
under review at the moment
that's good because carlos i wanted to
get a few more looks
at that catching right field
amidst the fan
i mean we really had no clue what was
going on i think it went through
different set of hands and then it ended
up in his glove is it interference at
the end of the day he ended up with the
baseball
in the mid so
i mean that looks clean to me right
there i think that's an out no problem
that's excellent concentration john
with the parks not having full capacity
of course you're you're subject to where
their fans are located
jd had one of those rare home runs the
other night off that pole
down the line which
can't be
other than a nightmare for a pitcher
do you cringe when you see that 326 feet
on that homer for jd on monday off the
pesky pull yeah that that is
part of the deal though
it is a difficult corner i mean there is
absolutely no foul territory there
you're running full speed to try to
catch that baseball you're going towards
the wall you know that if you drop it
it's a fair ball and then you have now
fans to factor in i'm sure that rosarito
doesn't mind that you know players want
fans in the stands but that is one of
the most difficult spots uh to play
defense at in this entire ballpark
[Music]
and we will continue
the first inning jd back to the plate
i'm a little surprised
it's one of those where despite the
rules
and it being out of play because it
touches a fan you wish carlos
that for this case the rule doesn't
exist because think about the
concentration how difficult it is to
deal with the surroundings but
ball's dead jd
is going to step up with nobody on and
two outs and we'll continue the first
inning
yes he gets another opportunity to swing
that bat this is not what the rays want
and yes i do agree with you scotty i
mean when you look at that play you say
wait a second arrozana just made a great
defensive play and
it really looks common sense will tell
you the guy should be out but if you go
to the nitty-gritty of the rule
then interference is called or
the ball is dead and now here we have jd
uh with another shot
uh perhaps going placata you never know
so
we'll see if they can able to close out
visiting well good news for the pitcher
because this can be a mentally uh
difficult situation had there been
runners on and he had to come back after
getting the third out we see the replay
one more time and
can't quite see the perfect angle but
you know it's so it got touched
from a pitcher's standpoint you just got
out a great hitter and you're like oh
shoot i gotta go back out and face this
great hitter who in the early starts of
this season has made already the
adjustments he talked about wanting to
make that he couldn't make last year he
crushed changeups last year and he's
really good against left-handed breaking
balls
uh with his power of five home runs
since the all-star break of 2019 on
breaking balls off a left-hander
jd it leads baseball in extra base hits
for about a week into the season he has
seven of them already
you know as a pitcher the one thing
about great hitters is you can look at
all the videos and see all the
information but their ability to adjust
from year to year and even in season
is why they're great hitters it's why
you can't just pitch them one way
even though the information will tell
you some of his weaknesses
that one on the ground gobbled up at
third
and wendell retires martinez so that
will officially conclude the first
inning scoreless at fenway park live on
youtube
hi i'm ryan yarbrough i'm a pitcher for
the tampa bay rays and this is google
why did ryan yarbrough
play baseball
started in t-ball about four years old
always had a love for the game and uh
just kept playing my whole life and
really fortunate to be able to play at
the big league level
why does ryan yarbrough
have short hair because
my long hair looks like a mop and it's
just nobody wants to see that so we keep
it short and honestly keeps the wife
happy
why ryan yarbrough
left-handed
don't know you know what just like
that's what what felt right i don't know
why if anybody knows why they're
certain handed it just kind of what
feels comfortable
why ryan yarbrough
tall again i think it's just genetics
honestly
why ryan yarbrough named ryan
just because my parents liked the name i
don't honestly don't know what other
names they were thinking but
obviously
i'm okay with it
[Music]
the first mlb game of the week live on
youtube in 2021 presented by fidelity
scott braun john smoltz carlos pena and
alana rizzo is at the ballpark in boston
as the red sox go for the sweep of the
tampa bay rays
this series has had a little bit of
everything native aldi back to work
a bit upstairs
brandon lau in the fourth spot for tampa
bay
strength against strength if he's going
to throw fastballs up brandon loves it
up you got to get him out down
you see what that target is the
curveball to his back foot it gave him
so much trouble last year in his heart
hard to get
a good
i don't know i'd say you guess average
on low fastballs is not good against
brandon so he likes the ball middle up
to middle in
there's your big swing
couldn't catch up to 97.
brandon lau finished in eighth place in
almbp voting last year he was the best
regular season performer for tampa bay
very streaky in the playoffs but did pop
a few big homers
yeah the eye-popping number or statistic
that i saw when doing some research is
the lowest batting average against
pitches right there but a fastball down
the lowest batting average in major
league baseball so you can tell what
he's trying to feast off of the new
power arms that are trying to get the
ball off
and he typically won't miss a lot of
them it's just that's where you want to
get them down
and he'll mostly pull those baseballs
but carlos remember in the world series
he hit three home runs all of them to
the opposite
field yes and that's when you know he's
going good i mean here against ivaldi he
needs to get really early enough to be
able to get to that upper uh you know
90s fastball placed in the upper side of
the of the strike zone so
um very difficult to do but it's a
matter of timing i i love this kid's
swing i mean lao really
has a very crisp delivery of the barrel
to the baseball and the numbers speak
for themselves
they do you can see he was
one of the best second baseman in
baseball last year
along with dj le mayhew of course 3-2
spotted
[Applause]
that's that splitter
that's the splitter that really has
taken a baldy and his second track back
to starting since coming back from
injuries if he's got that pitch going
right there
it definitely takes the sting out of the
hitter trying to get ready for 97 98.99
12 pitch first inning from naty baldy
it's already the
seventh pitch or make an eighth pitch of
the second
and that's yandy diaz
you know this year i'm going to be
really intrigued to see how the rays
over 162
you know the approach last year i don't
think could have continued over 162 but
it made it work and they took advantage
of it they thought you know 60 games
it's not like it surprised anybody you
knew what was going to happen and they
were able to no pun intended cash in on
that on that kind of theory and
philosophy that they took towards last
year but this year 162 with the offense
they have and the pitching style and
philosophies they have
will that be sustainable over 162 that's
what we're going to find out
of course everyone thinks back to game
six of the world series blake snell
dealing and then removed
and most of the world said removed too
soon
alana rizzo what did you think of the
tampa bay rays from last
year well i mean i was on the other side
of it scotty being with the los angeles
dodgers for seven seasons i was very
thankful to kevin cash for pulling blake
snell when he pulled him but again going
through all the different scenarios and
he was talking to john smalls about this
earlier today it's that's kind of the
worst case scenario that played out
right in front of his eyes and i asked
him the question i said would you have
made that decision again
and he said absolutely i said i guess
you can sleep then knowing that in that
moment that was the best decision he
thought for his club and what smokey was
talking about you know the style that
they have and the way that they play is
it going to sustain over 162 game season
he said you know some teams are built
that have nine guys to win it we have 26
guys that's what we use
and one of them is joey wendell who
flies out to [ __ ] hernandez in center
field who was part of that world series
last year and won a ring with the
dodgers another tidy inning from nady
baldy will head to the bottom of the
second
[Music]
he shoots this one into deep right
that's got a chance to go and it's out
of here off the facing of the upper deck
on a no two pitch austin meadows does it
again
here's a high fly ball back into left
duvall is going to have to go to the
wall that baby's gone
home run for manuel bargo and the rays
lead two to nothing
enzo nino hits one deep to left and boy
they're gonna cash in
bonito hits it out of here the raids
grab a 2-1 lead so here is johnny diaz
and he drives one through the right side
and this is going to get down for a base
hit and maybe roll all the way to the
wall margot will score here comes
wendell around third he's going to be
waved home throw to the plate is
not in time it's a two-run double for
yandi diaz and the rays have taken the
lead it's six to four
shoots this one into right on the run
a diving catch he'll get up the tag by
vasquez he will score but oh my what a
grab by a rosarito
[Applause]
[Music]
home half of the second at fenway park
with four five and six due up and here's
a new
feature that we're going to amplify this
year on youtube another unique aspect of
watching the game our interactive
polling feature allows you to offer
multiple choice response to questions
posed in the live game commentary so
stay tuned as the results will be
revealed and discussed later in the
broadcast of course we'll have everyone
weigh in super easy to do pull right in
front of you we're gonna bring it more
than ever who's gonna have the biggest
impact on today's game nice and simple
predictions arose arena meadows bogarts
or jd martinez you want me to answer yes
i'm going to see
the guy at the plate right now
that's just my gut just like that
he loves lefties
so it's more than your gut it's an
informed decision i like it
xander bogarts takes a strike and now
it's time to welcome our fidelity
interview guest martine perez joins us
from the red sox dug out martine thanks
for joining us how you doing today
good guy how are you
we are doing well thanks for hanging
with us for this bottom of the second
and yarborough deals it's a weekly hit
ball to third and wendell throws it away
[Applause]
so bogart's reaches and already is
starting to make john smoltz look good
martine let's start
with your latest performance how did you
feel yesterday i feel great i think uh
it was pounding the sauna really good
and
throw a lot of to see my skin
and everything
work they waited out that i that i was
you know supposed to do but what's great
was falling last night
martine i like watching guys that know
how to pitch and you know
in a day day and era where there's so
much velocity and that's all we talk
about
talk to me about how you use the
information as
you know how to pitch and don't rely so
much on velocity
uh
i think you know more than than us i
mean everything is where you're gonna
throw the ball you know
i know velocity is good sometime but
it don't mean
for me that you need to throw 100 every
time to get people out i think
if you put the ball where you want it
you're going to have a good results so
that's the way that i've been pitching
right now i have a lot of information
from the heaters and uh
i just like to go out there and use it
that the way that i can pitch just
trying to move the ball and stay down
with uh with the heaters that i know
they don't hit both downs or
all the uh the heaters they don't they
don't hit the wall the opening so
that's the that's that's that's how i
like to pitch right now because
you know
and the year before throw
96 97 and i got
hit too easy so now it's time for me to
just move the ball and and throw a lot
of stride you're just trying to hit the
glove every time i'm gonna go to the
home plate and let me ask you a
follow-up as a visitor when i pitched
there the wall was in the back of my
mind i pitched according to the wall i
don't know if that was good or not back
then but how does the wall affect you
knowing that this ball park is so unique
and you pitch it home
you know what i don't think too much in
the wall because
i've been pitching here
you know last year and
when i was with the rangers and the
twins a pitch here too and and
that the wall don't affect me
and i have great numbers here but uh
like i say i just you know just trying
to focus
on the heaters just trying to get you
know most hitters out and
and at the end and i just trying to give
you a chance to my team to win the game
that's all about it
martin you you've heard
people talk about okay you can only go
inside if you throw 90
in the upper 90s you can only go up and
in if you throw 97.96
but you are throwing more inside and
more up in the zone than ever before
where does that come from
uh
i talk a lot with ac with alice and uh
you know we checked the numbers before
we came here to boston and
they don't they don't hit
i don't have too many hit or
or they don't hit well opening against
me so that's what i'm trying to do right
now just trying to stop my fastball in
and up and and
you know
after going with the cutter in i mean i
work good for me so it's one thing that
i have in my mind right now and
and and you know after i do the job
opening i can go down in a way with with
the change or cut it outside so that's
one thing that we've been doing spring
training and now we just hannah we're
just gonna do here
in the season two
bogart's on first after the infield
single
and now christian vazquez watches the
pitch sail outside
a ball in two strikes
hey martine what did you think of native
aldi in his opening day performance and
then what have you seen from him so far
today
i think he's attacking a little bit more
you know he got a
great stuff man
he's
he can
he can use all his speeches but uh i
think now he's on more on the control
and he throw more fish more first
preferred strike so that's important for
us you know i think uh
first pitch
is a kid you know
when you go out there you gotta you
gotta throw strikes
uh
quick you don't have to wait too much to
attack the heater so
one thing that they always like to do is
just
throw a lot of stride to the heaters and
don't give too much credit to
them because they get comfortable that's
when you got paid
here's another look
at the raise fielder's choice
going the short way to second not in
time to first so vazquez replaces
bogarts
at first
talking to martin perez during this home
half of the second scoreless between the
rays and the red sox live on youtube and
hunter renfro will dig in also for our
creators
hanging out with us
in the chat room give us a few questions
for martin perez and we will ask him
alive during this half inning
i have another one for you martine after
this
first pitch from yarber to renfro in
there for strike one
so martine
give me more on your relationship with
the cutter and i believe when we spoke a
few years back you picked up
some of the tricks of the trade from
jayco to rizzi am i correct
yes you're right uh that was in 2019
uh
my first first week no i think was the
last week of spring training
uh my agent felix olivo he always told
me hey martin i think you gotta try and
you have to try to throw a cutter
and i always say no because i have a
great changeup i had great curba
and i have a
fourth team and then to see
and at that time i get uh i gave up a
lot of ground balls
but that year i'll say okay this is a
new year new team and and why why not
try something i mean it's never slay to
try things and and putting on game and
i remember all the research told me hey
martin this is how you're gonna throw
your your cutter you don't have to do
much with your hands you're just trying
to throw like a cut fastball and let's
see what happened and i remember i throw
eight
eight quarters in a row in the whole pin
and as soon as i feel good and i feel
strong with my hands
at the time that i throw the ball
i say i got it and they asked me you're
gonna throw in again i went yes why not
i mean it's time for competing and i
feel good with this pitch
uh i'm gonna try it and uh after that
man everything was you know i i was
totally different pitcher you know
especially because i had great change up
and
that quarter helped me a lot too
you know
especially when when you're behind in
the count so you get people out quick
well martine it's working for you and
and i'm sure you give jake a text every
once in a while saying thank you and we
want to thank you for joining us for
this half pinning oh i know he knows
he's probably watching too getting ready
for tonight hey martine thanks for
joining us and good luck the rest of the
way okay
thank you very much have a good have a
good day guys you too the raised turn
two two in the books no score from
fenway
[Music]
goes the other way for a base hit into
right field so hernandez is quickly
aboard well that is so nicely done right
there he stayed back stayed back and
with two strikes you're gonna love this
jd martinez laying into one and a heidi
drive left center field up there
and that ball is gone the red sox hit
their first home run
of 2021 jd martinez will touch them all
off
into right field racing back to rosarito
can't get it almost got out of here it's
off the bullpen fence katie martinez
trying to score
and the throw won't get him throwback to
third is down the line and zander is up
and he will score
2-2 coming
fly ball well struck center field
ago
we'll see that off the bottom of the
wall
red sox looking to add on here's the
throw home and gonzales slides in
[Applause]
went after that one off the outside
corner down the line that one's sailing
and it is gone
into the pesky pole
a three-run homer for jd martinez
hey new to the mlb game of the week for
the 2021 season is the youtube player of
the game where fans watching on mobile
devices and computers can vote for which
player will receive a trophy during the
post game show trophy will be in hand
for the post game show stay tuned for
the player of the game polling options
later in the show great way to get
involved just like our creator sending
us great questions for martine perez but
then the rays turn two and all of a
sudden we're off to the top of the third
inning with manny margaux leading off
seven eight and nine coming up for tampa
bay chopper over ivaldi and here comes
bogart's bare-handed for the out
what a play right there
santa bourgeois showing what he's
capable of doing you know he did not
waste any time in charging this baseball
as soon as he saw it he went after it
and he knows who's running he has to
hurry he's bare-handed very cleanly
very athletic move
we shouldn't ever take this for granted
i mean that is a lot harder than it
looks
and again making john smoltz look good
as he selected bogarts for
which player would have the biggest
impact in the game today so that might
be your pick if he keeps this up for the
player of the game later on john
i'll tell you what he's had an impact
ever since he got to this organization
his young shortstop he handled himself
way beyond his years he's been
continuously improving
and he's going to uh
he has a chance to be in this
organization the longest and in the face
of this organization for a long time
francisco mejia squibs one down the left
side
and he's gonna turn that into extra
bases
jd martinez corrals it in the corner and
it's a one out double
for the d or for the catcher this
afternoon
dh yesterday
known for his hitting prowess in the
minor leagues and every once in a while
you get one of these
carlos you know he has a very high
probability swing it's a level uh hack
through the zone and when he catches
balls late
deep into the strike zone he's able to
hit low line drives or low ground balls
ground balls down the other way so
that's just good hitting it's a product
of a very nice level swing
matching is doubles total from last year
at one
that's towards the left side it's for
devers taking his time
high throw brought down by the tall
bobby doll back over at first two gone
you know we didn't get a chance to talk
about adamus because he made that quick
out but he's one of the guys i'm looking
for to see how he rebounds off of last
year the way it ended he really
struggled at the plate he's an energy
high-energy type guy in this or you know
in this ball club he means so much to
him and i think
you know getting off to a good start and
kind of erasing the last memory you had
when you finished the season
yeah alex cora said devers showed up
after the pandemic shutdown not in the
best shape
it showed early on he started to pick
things up in the month of september
some of his stat cast numbers were at an
all-time high
at the end of the shortened season
exit velocity hard hit percentage
all the talent in the world
and a world series ring already
back to the top of the lineup in yoshi
susugo
i promised that we would receive picks
not just from you john but also from
carlos and alana so carlos player with
the biggest impact today out of jd
xander randy
and austin and we'll reveal those
results pretty soon who's your pick i'm
gonna go with jd martinez i mean he had
two very good swings seems like he is
seeing the baseball wealth yarborough
jd with the walk-off in the 12th inning
yesterday for the red sox
suzugo grounded out
in the top of the first
top of the zone fastball right here
middle to middle in
i don't believe suzugo tesugo would have
the
ability to barrel that pitch up right
now on a 2-2 after seeing a breaking
ball
eval has flashed all five pitches
already today
off the end of the bat broken bat and
it's gonna fall in front of hernandez
here comes mejia and he's in there
sugo drives in the first run of the day
for tampa bay it's one nothing
we'll see what happens with the final
result as they look at it but that
didn't like that pitch on off speed
split after a guy was really struggling
with fastball velocity and he gave him a
chance to get the bat on the ball this
is a tough one
when you see the splitter right there it
stays in the strike zone doesn't tumble
and he hits it off the end of the bat
and
that's one you're going to go back and
go i know if i execute it's still an out
but i like my chances better with
velocity over the middle of the zone
you can't get much better on that road
too
yeah i would agree with that 100 percent
uh small t i mean
slow and then followed by another off
speed we just get into the cadence of of
the timing and suzuka was able to put uh
the barrel on that baseball and driving
and run
so here comes austin meadows
who popped out in foul ground in the
first
did that just miss no
i'm sitting next to a pitcher let's
bring in alana
guys we know that ivaldi typically
throws a billion alex cora joked that he
never has to worry about the velocity
it's always there but it seems like he's
been using his cutter a lot more in his
second outing getting some poor contact
or weak contact if you will and i'm
curious to know guys from both a pitcher
and a hitter's perspective we can talk
about it next inning do you have to
pick one or the other you can't do both
as far as timing is concerned i'd like
to hear what your thoughts are on that
yeah we'll bring that question in when
we return for the bottom of the third
hunter renfro with the shoestring catch
ivaldi's shaking his head because he
gave up a run but also received some
help
[Music]
he loves the game what a career hall of
famer
and he's from here that's why they
retired that number two it wasn't that
he played that long but
he's a local guy here's bonds hitting it
deep to right field it's gone
the first double raise home run wade
boggs takes the grand tour
and he needs
199 hits for 3 000.
here comes wade boggs to a standing
ovation at tropicana field
needing one more hit to get to 3 000.
and there's a drive
hit that makes history
is
[Applause]
one nothing tampa bay let's bring in the
results of our first poll question a
little prediction action biggest impact
in this game and the crowd votes jd 38
of the share
same with carlos's pick and smoltzy your
pick goes in the two spots xander
bogart's red sox fans weighing in hard
this afternoon
jd the man yesterday with the walk-off
hit in the 12th
that's a familiar sight too
outfielders checking out cards seeing
where they should stand
carlos we see a lot of that nowadays as
christian arroyo gets ready for the red
sox half of the third
we've seen that even with pitchers
pitchers taking
little cards out of their back pocket
and kind of checking maybe for signs or
perhaps
some
scouting report that help
could help a pitcher sequence better and
strategize
this is how far we've come in this game
and i think it's sufficient is great if
it allows you to win ball games why not
christian arroyo swings through the off
speed stuff from ryan yarbrough
still on a roll today for tampa bay he
hasn't given up a run
in a long time not this season and going
back to last season
up to 17 consecutive scoreless innings
dating back to 2020.
let's bring alana back lana the
inning rudely interrupted the finish to
your report
hate it when that happens scotty no my
question for the guys was if aldi we
know he throws a billion and he's using
a cutter a lot today lots of poor
contact so far on that cutter the race
hitters in my opinion kind of need to
pick one pitch right i mean timing wise
you can't necessarily cover both cpu you
either have to be on the fastball or the
cutter so from a hitter's perspective do
you kind of just have to pick one and go
with it and from a pitcher's perspective
john how important is it to be able to
kind of make them continue to guess
i'll go first lana you know when we're
trying to hit up there
to cover both speeds it's virtually
impossible especially if you're able to
hide pitch as well in other words if the
pitches look exactly the same but yet
they have different timings
so it's very important if you're going
to sit fastball hard you stay with it
you stay with that cadence you stay with
that time and you get ready early enough
to get to it and then
hopefully you take the off speed or if
you're going to swing one because you
got fooled you swing through it you
don't modify your swing now that takes a
lot of discipline it is uh easier said
than done but that's the only way to
assure
that you're going to have some good
hacks at the baseball you have to pick
one or the other
and i would say from a pitcher's
standpoint you know today's philosophy
is totally different if a lot of hitters
have a one-way swing then you've got to
hit their bat in the area and so if you
can't put pressure on a hitter by
changing lanes and changing directions
away from a right and left-handed hitter
then that area becomes the focus for the
hitter the swing path just stays the
same so if the splitter doesn't break
and you're thinking you know fastball
but like we saw there and it doesn't
break and it's in the area of a swing
path there's no difference to the hitter
that's why i think pitching has still
got to create stress on the hitters by
having not only your best stuff
but the ability to change eye levels and
the focus of you just can't just swing
one way against me and i think a lot of
hitters have been able to take advantage
of velocity based on that because
there's no different approach and if a
hitter or pitcher doesn't make them
change or they're unwilling to change a
pitcher will have success so ivaldi in
my opinion
when he pitches off his fastball has to
remember where that last fastball was
either taken or swung and then pitch
effectively off of that
broken bat arroyo into the glove of lao
and the reason in the past he's been hit
too hard for a guy who throws 99 he
doesn't have a lot of movement on his
pitch so that's why he throws the cutter
to create movement to get it off the
barrel that's why the split goes
opposite of what the left-handed hitter
should see but when they mirror each
other and the velocity change of speeds
is not that great the hitter is not
in i don't well i guess you intimidated
or alters anything that he's doing and
you can
literally go up there and
swing from your heels and find one of
those pitches in the zone that you like
and take advantage of his power
bobby dalbeck known for his power but
drops went into center field
seeing eyes single
to start things off in the third for
boston
i could talk hitting all day that's
molten you bring a great point uh
forward you know right here dobba gets
that uh fastball kind of like a cutter
type
inside and he's able to get to it
yarborough will use that pitch to crowd
hitters but but dulbeck was ready early
enough and you can make that adjustment
because the differential what's multi
was talking about the speed differential
isn't that great from the fastball up so
if you start with your fastball up
mentality you're probably going to be on
time for that cutter speed differential
is a huge huge deal if you're going to
have success as a pitcher
that's in there to kevin
number nine hitter
you know we can complicate so many
things and the simple rule that i always
adopted based on the hitter i was facing
is if he swung at a high fastball
and didn't put it in play i followed it
with a curveball
because that plane of his eyes what he
last saw was was what he remembers if he
threw if i threw a low fast ball in the
outer part of the plate and he swung or
fouled off
i would follow by a slider because the
planes are the same if you get too
creative and you throw a high fast ball
followed by a low slider that variance
of the hitter is too big and anyone who
swings at that is just a free swinger
and the same thing i would say facing a
left-hander if i if i got an outside
fastball that he swung or took for a
strike then i followed with a split
going away you've got to be able to
create an awareness to the hitter that
they have some kind of fear of what the
guy on the mound has and
it's hard to eliminate
things in this game if you've got a
jacob degrom all right he's obviously
the best that some of the best we have
but i think the information sometimes
and this has been my my i've been
wanting to talk
years about this the information of a
pitcher getting on and scott braun as a
hitter
i'm i think too many pitchers pitch to
your weakness
versus pitching to their strength the
pitcher strength meaning my strength is
what it is
it's got to be glaring
if a hitter can't hit a curveball for
example you know and so what i think
yarbrough and even the baldy do
they're going to pitch off their
strengths yarbol right here has so many
more movement pitches
that's why he doesn't need all the
velocity that let's say avaldi has
because ivaldi's movement is not as good
as yarbrough and of course left-handers
i always say if you're left-handed
breathing and throw strikes you're going
to be in the big leagues
because they have such an advantage with
that that angle that hitters just don't
see all the time statcast 3d powered by
google cloud giving us a nice look at
the repertoire from ryan yarbrough and
this is exactly what he queues up weak
contact lazy fly ball for brandon lau
to head out and haul in
and that's all it takes you know uh if
you just are able to get slightly
different timing right there that swing
was slightly early it's just good enough
for the hitter to hit that ball off the
end of the bat no damage done now if you
try to sit back a little bit you're like
wait i gotta sit back i gotta wait well
he comes with that cutter and now you're
late on the cutter hitting the ball off
the handle and that's that's the art of
pitching and this is precisely what's
mostly was uh explaining with throwing
the fastball away then following up with
a a split off of the same line or the
high fastball and then the kerbal that
is the simplest uh way of explaining
tunneling so everyone at home we just
got a lesson in
pitching from john smalls and
that that alone will take you a long way
to become a decent pitcher on the mount
and the good news is this is on youtube
you can scroll back very easily you can
watch this back at any time it's a free
game globally take notes and if you
forget it's right in front of you
easy rewind
dolbeck off of first and [ __ ] hernandez
evens up the count
small to you know what i wanted to ask
you when you're on the mound you have
i've heard you mention a couple times
like well if i see that the hitter
swings at that pitch or if he takes it
what you're saying is that you are
reading the hitter correct the best you
can try to do i mean a lot of guys
you know mechanics doesn't allow them to
take their head it takes their head away
from the reaction of the hitter so you
rely on the catcher and information but
i learned so much from greg maddox who
was able to finish in a position where
he could read the swing so much better
than anybody else it effectively gave
him a menu of options and knew why
he was so good at outguessing the hitter
right
and
i don't know how many hitters today you
know back in our era more hitters
guessed and we're guest hitters to try
to create the i don't know how many guys
even do that now they kind of
kind of swing with their swing is what
their swing is and so in-game
adjustments are huge for a lot of
pitchers who can do that some guys have
to go to use the video some guys need to
watch their start and so you learn how
to do that and rely on your catcher and
information because if you
moved in the box from one bat to another
and i didn't notice that i'm in trouble
what about that called
it's close that's the kind of pressure
you want to put on a hitter i'd throw
i'd try to come right back out there and
see if i could fade it just a little bit
more
and make that hitter think he can't take
one more pitch
he's been landing that cutter
where he wants it and he did he went
right back
ryan yarbrough
bringing it this afternoon for tampa bay
his team leads by a run
three in the books from fenway
[Music]
my goal is
to have my best year yet
you know
that's pretty much it to have my best
year i've ever had
got him
wait marwan
dang doogie you got a cannon
damn you got a cannon dog
he loves it he loves it
[Music]
stay with it
best time of the day
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
the rays pounced first they score a run
in the third now do up in the fourth
inning rosarina lau and diaz and
that man's part of our next poll
question who will win al rookie of the
year yeah hard to believe but arose
arena did not qualify as a rookie last
year didn't play enough games so he's on
the list so is wander franco who's not
on the big league squad yet
and jared kellnick and ryan mount castle
round out our four
let's focus our fidelity player
spotlight on the top prospect in all of
major league baseball yes the rays make
it to the world series yet the rich get
richer in terms of talent this man is
coming soon to a ballpark near you
i know a lot of them wish it was sooner
and i understand
both sides of it
patience
and he looks like a special talent i had
none of that early in my career
practice
minor leagues forget that
that's for dabbers
one away
here's the last at-bat from brandon lau
as he gets ready to face naty baldy
again
how did it go for him last time well
he struck out looking and ivaldi was
just throwing the entire menu at him
carlos
yes you see the combination of the
up fastball in the zone paired up with
the cutter and then you see the slower
curveball
trying to allow us in between and like
alana was saying you have to pick one
otherwise you're gonna be in trouble
threw all five of his pitches in that
at-bat he did and he didn't throw him
exactly where he wanted to he got away
with a couple of them and again his
scouting report is what it is you go on
your and it looks like he's just a
little erratic meaning of aldi
on his fastball command to basketball
command to me is going to be set up as
other pitches and take the pressure off
of it
and when you have classic get the ball
down well you got to get ahead to get
the ball down to get this guy out
because if you get behind and the ball
up he crushes
to me pitching
i used to always want to know a couple
simple things is the guy aggressive is
he want to hit the first pitch will he
take you know does he want to take a
walk because if you're not going to take
a walk against me you're out
but if you make me pitch
or like this at classic at-bat he didn't
go up there jumpy he made a vaulty pitch
this is the good things that the rays
can do when you think about their walks
homer strikeout type philosophy poor
pitch free pass
you up there it doesn't mean that you go
up there taking pictures right it's
multi right as a hitter we are waiting
for a pitch we want to hit but we have
to be aggressive
in the zone where we want it and that
would allow us to actually take some uh
balls and get more walks so it's
it's it's a it's one of those uh
things that if you hit you walk more so
the more aggressive you are in your zone
you will end up walking more because
you're just more discriminating as a
hitter
that's exactly what lau did three of the
past six raise hitters have reached base
that misses low to yandy diaz
it's funny what you learn in this game
when you play long enough and i'll never
forget uh
one of my uh
guys i pitched against came to me after
an outing and said i'll never swing at
your slider again and of course i didn't
believe him he's a right-handed hitter
i'm like there's no way you can lay off
the slider so i faced him however many
times that he never swung at my slider
again and what it indirectly taught me
was i didn't want to throw my slider for
a strike i wanted it to look like a
strike and up for a ball he taught me
indirectly how to learn to throw my
slider for a strike anytime i wanted in
case hitters started to have that
approach
because when a guy goes up there and
swings wild at it
like that's a good take but that's a
great pitch
and so because the count allowed him to
take that pitch and spit on it as a
hitter would say if it was the opposite
account there's no way if it was like
one and two or one he can't lay off that
pitch so the count and a lot of things
about pitching
determine whether the hither has stress
or is going to be aggressive and
you saw rosarina the first pitch he
determined he was going to swing out of
the hand of the pitcher it wasn't even
close it led
that at bat to be three straight
breaking balls
now ivaldi has missed on seven of his
last
eight tosses
yeah and that's what i was talking about
he's kind of slinging it like he does
but the location he's missing too big in
spots
and it's putting him in the
defensive account
i love people that used to go well it's
3-1 fastball like just throw it again
3-2 it's not that easy to keep throwing
everything where you want it
diaz swings through
that was a great combination right there
small if you watched the pitch prior to
that was that up and in fastball and
diaz was laid on it and then he throws
the slider off of exactly the same line
and diaz is ahead of it because he
remembered that he was laid on the
fastball on the previous pitch and
that's what you were talking about
smolty that
fastball command it's so key to pitching
and right there those last two uh
offerings
pretty much
it's it's a perfect example of what good
tunneling is all about
three four seam fastballs three sliders
in that sequence against yandy diaz for
a second strikeout of the day now joey
wendell
who flew out to center fields back in
the second
i'll bring in some of those comments
from the creators hanging out with us on
youtube today
jolly olives says 20 mile per hour
difference between ivaldi's fastball and
curveball gross
well for wendell and most of his
strikeouts i mean that's the highest
statistic i've seen in a long time of
non-fastball strikeouts are out of the
zone so he's chasing non-fastballs
out of the zone and by a large margin
the highest in all the baseball last
year
so i wouldn't this pitch should be
nowhere close to the strike zone
he does have a little success against
ivaldi
five for eight with a homer in the past
would that mean anything to you yeah oh
yeah that's not small anytime a number
starts with a six as an average
it's pretty good representation that he
sees the ball better than what the
pitcher is hoping he would do so you got
to do something to change the way he
sees it
see there's the pitch right there that's
not even close
flowecky cleans it up
a pair of punch-outs for native aldi
in the fourth impressive finish to the
half-inning we'll see if the red sox
have their first answer of the day
coming up in the bottom of the fourth
[Music]
randia rosarina used to have dreams that
looked kind of like this
in them he'd be the man in the middle of
everything treasured by his teammates
and loved by his little girl
arrived in the states he says he wasn't
comfortable showing his personality and
often felt alone
now he's not only one of the guys he is
the guy
living the life he once dreamed of
foreign
[Music]
it's one nothing raise after three and a
half adding to this unique viewing
experience don't forget to check out
youtube's live game commentary featuring
mlb the raise the red sox accounts run
by will middlebrooks today and a select
group of youtube creators joining us you
can view the live game commentary on
your computer your mobile device if
you're watching on your smart tv we'll
be keeping an eye on the discussion
throughout the broadcast and we are
featuring one special creator
for this afternoon's game
a friend of mlb
game of the week live on youtube giraffe
neck mark another new feature this year
an added focus on a single youtube
content creator featured in the live
game commentary our creator spotlight
shined on mark luino better known to
subscribers as giraffe neck mark an avid
new york mets fan mark's channel
features opinionated yet informative
videos about all things mlb from jerseys
and stadiums to season predictions and
the beauty of it is he's great in the
chat with us always contributing
comments remember him from last year and
the year before and i want to make sure
mark that
i pronounced your name right because
we've never met and i'm always calling
him giraffe neck marks so in the
comments you gotta
lay out your pronunciation for us and
i'll make sure that i was accurate there
but thank you for joining us today
and your thoughts on the game please as
well as we approach
the halfway mark pretty soon here with
the rays leading one to nothing
other comments rolling in movie gaming
tv tunneling for the win and stark
raving sports saying pitch sequencing
really getting into it in the last half
inning
for native aldi and then we see
a lot of that excellence
from this soft tossing lefty as well
ryan yarbrough
scoreless baseball so far he's facing
devers martinez and bogarts the big
names for boston coming up
devers wants to get rid of a little
streak he's got going against
left-handers that hasn't been very good
hitless in
the last 20 or so at bass against
left-handers he'll get going he stays on
the ball
about as well as any youngster when he
got in this league
image of hitting
chapman 102 for a homer
great memory from his rookie season
here's the longest active scoreless
inning streak in baseball yarbrough
number two to joe musgrove
new member of the padres
yarbo street goes back to september 20th
here's the time devers does invite he
chased on a curveball last time for
strike three here's what i think needs
to change over time about baseball and
pitching
yarbor yarbrough is doing what he's
doing but he won't be given as many
chances as a guy like a baldi's
counterpart you know because velocity is
always going to get you to the big
leagues and give you more chances but
when you have a guy that knows how to
pitch
and the effectiveness that he has shown
in being able to deliver soft contact
there's a spot in every team for that
kind of guy we're just not looking for
it as much anymore so i hope there's a
re
i guess a
rejuvenation of pitchers
that know how to pitch but maybe can't
light up the radar gun as much
so if you're a high schooler right now
and you're throwing in the mid 80s
you can get to 90 and live in this
league you don't need to get to 95. yeah
i think there's
i agree but again those choices that are
being made and the reward system in the
game is feeding the type of pitching
that we have today
but i believe it has a shelf life i've
always said it has a shelf life because
it's not sustainable to i call it rpm
redline your pitches every time meaning
if you go on a car and the tachometer in
that car
there's a reason why there's a red line
for your engine try to stay in that red
line for about an hour and a half and
see what happens to your engine over
time and i think pitchers are finding
out unfortunately the hard way it's hard
to stay healthy emptying the tank every
single time you pitch
and it doesn't necessarily keep you
uh
succeeding i mean you can throw as hard
as you want we've seen it many times
over and over again in the big leagues
guys that throw in the upper 90s and
they still get hit
um and they do not have success so it's
not all about speed
it's about knowing how to pitch excuse
me swing from martinez and after a
bobble at first cesugo is able to clean
it up and hand it off to yarbrough
devers moves on to second
oh the old spring training pfp pitchers
fundamentals this is where a pitcher's
got to be ready to go over there just in
case something like that happens
you know
that play gets practiced not quite like
that
but they did a nice job cleaning it up
taking advantage of jd not being a
speedster not panicking getting the out
took so much pride in my defense we
forget pitchers are still a defender
after they let go of the ball not a lot
of them
finish in a position to be a good
defender because of the way they throw a
baseball
but i tell you what that is something
that can help you win one two maybe
three baseball games out of 30 some
that's a
that's a big deal when you're fielding
your position
and becoming the ninth defender if you
will on the field
and that would make carlos pena's job
easier
communication and just repetition it's
key and that's why we go to pfps it's
not the most fun of things but they must
be done it's a priority in spring
training and i think they should keep on
doing it throughout the season it's just
not let's do it in spring training and
be done at least maybe once a week small
to get out there and do a couple of pfps
it wouldn't it wouldn't hurt well club
well if i was playing with carlos my
communication would go like this if i'm
running over to first you better throw
me the ball because i'm not running over
there for my help no
there's two there'd be too many guys
that at first base the pitcher's running
all the way over there and he waves them
off i got it i got it
and carlos is one of the nicest humans
on the planet so you'd be like
sure smotzy no problem
sure i'll i'll let you place multi of
course i'm not gonna make you come all
the way over here and not give you the
ball
no chance
you're a good man carlos this is xander
bogarts with devers on second
this is a tease in our industry i'm
about to give you a tease for all the
viewers on youtube
in a little bit later whatever that
works out to we're going to show you how
when you don't communicate with your
first baseman how things can go bad
and a play
that i was involved in so we'll get that
to you so that you can understand the
hows and the how not to
you don't want to miss this
[Laughter]
stay tuned
golfs it to center and that's gonna fall
in front of margot
rounding third is devers and he's gonna
score
xander bogarts evens this game up at one
with the rbi knock
he's just too good against left-handed
pitchers right now he's just too good in
general he's not a
it's one of those simple approach
doesn't miss his pitch
but he has really had success against
left-handed pitching
over the course of his career and
there's that cutter that comes in but he
stays inside the ball and doesn't try to
do too much that's the key
if you got a guy trying to do too much
and hit that ball over the green monster
that's an out
it's a good point small you see how he
just kept that swing level through the
zone he doesn't crush that baseball hits
it a little bit on the label but because
of that nice level
path he's able to still hit that
okay slow line drive but still in the
right trajectory that gets the job done
how good is this guy you know since 2015
has been one of the best short stops in
the game
that's the seventh hit of the series for
xander bogarts
carlos this is the guy i wanted to ask
you about why for whatever reason the
last two years power has clicked into
his game i mean he's gone from okay
decent power to
what what clicks for a hitter to engage
the power component in in in each guy's
career
approach multi you know i've had the
privilege of speaking to vasquez about
this because it seems like just like you
have observed obviously the numbers
speak for themselves but when i was
looking at his timing mechanism it
seemed like he was getting in cadence
with the pitches a lot
better than in previous years and alana
asked that question earlier in today's
telecast where it's like hey
you know do you have to you have to pick
one or the other you cannot be in
between vasquez used to be one of those
in-between guys and then over the last
few seasons he said you know what i'm
going to be ready for my fastball or at
times you admit this to me you know what
i know i'm going to get an off speed
pitch out over the plate and i am going
to commit to it so it's all about his
approach allows you to be on time for
the baseball and when you're on time you
put healthy swings on the ball and it
translates to more power
i mean look at that in 2018
light hitting catcher
pristine reputation on defense but he
had 10 home runs in his first four
seasons in the big leagues and then a
career-high 23 all of a sudden in 2019.
2-1 offering is blasted
christian vasquez lives up to his new
name and goes long
on cue scotty on cue we'll see what that
pitch was but it seemed like it was
something up and in it might have been
that cutter and christian vasquez was
ready for it he got ready early enough
to be able to get his swinging
and when we see this replay we'll be
able to see how healthy that hack was
through the zone and when you do that
give yourself a shot check check this
out small to see if we could go to this
replay and we could see what a healthy
swing looks like
and a healthy ride in the dugout it's
the new celebration you hit a homer
you ride the roller coaster but carlos
here was that healthy hack
yeah see the cutter inside vasquez takes
the swing you don't see him change his
mechanics or anything to try to adjust
to where the pitch is modifying his
swing to the baseball now he takes a
healthy cut almost like if he was
hitting off the tee well that is by the
sign he got ready for that pitch in the
up and in uh part of the strike zone and
that's why he gets that healthy hack
that we talk about
two run shot makes it 3-1 boston a homer
in back-to-back contests for christian
vasquez and the first regular season
home run allowed by yarbrough since
august 21st
a lot of times we will see hitters
kind of collapse in the backside kind of
pull off
and you may say man stay in there keep
your shoulder in but in reality what
we're seeing is symptoms of being late
so
when you have bad swings the first thing
you should ask yourself is was i on time
margot times that up in center
and sits down renfro
two outs christian arroyo stepping up
do you like that celebration in the
dugout i've actually seen it before and
and i can only think of
that might be dangerous to some older
guys that have to do that but the
younger guys can handle it
you might not be able to come out of the
car yeah yeah yeah
arroyo popped out to second in his first
trip
vasquez had the homer yesterday
in the ninth inning off diego castillo
saved the day for boston they end up
coming back three times
and winning in the 12th
i don't care what anyone says i've said
it long before it happened as you watch
this celebration
come flying through
i think that rule is here to stay i
think it's a great rule i know a lot of
people who played the game a long time
don't like the x raining rule but that
was a classic game last night of what
can happen
with the type of action starting a run
around second that game would not have
happened that way if it was under the
old rules
and could have gone on for 17 innings
and
drained everybody's bullpen i get that's
the rub of 162 games but
the reality of of what we're trying to
accomplish now in baseball and the
players
you know everybody talks about the
studies of keeping those people healthy
as much as possible extra innings is
people forget about how how hard extra
innings is and i think it's a great rule
and it turned into a fantastic game
because of that rule
yesterday was a roller coaster ride back
and forth battle between these two teams
off the end of the bat
loud didn't have to move much
and that sits down the side but not
before the red sox pounce
it's christian vasquez
bashing boston in front 3-1 red sox
after four
[Applause]
and here we go game one of the american
league championship series this crowd
really pumped for the red sox and the
rays we are finally ready for baseball
in the alcs
he struck him out
change up struck him out swinging
four six three on one pitch shield gets
the last two outs of the frame
strike three call
one out flip floyd at the plate swings
and misses four innings are complete
here at propaganda field we've got no
score in game one of the alcs so now
runners at second and third for the
left-handed hitting jed lowry fly ball
right field playable for gross there's
the catch tagging at third bay boston
takes a one-nothing lead
swing line drive left field crawford
coming on it's off his glove he rolls to
the
[Applause]
he gets the sign
he kicks and he fires and it swung on
and missed right three got him on a
splitter to end it the red sox win game
one of the american league championship
series
native aldi is pitching with an
advantage now in the fifth and we have
poll results rookie of the year in the
american league randy arose arena
is your winner
by a landslide
and
as manny margot takes strike one
we are going to bring in one of his
teammates for our second dugout
interview of the day and we'll ask in
this question too and also a reminder to
our youtube creators
bring those questions on to tyler
glasnow right now oh perfect there he is
he predicted there we go rookie of the
year tyler glasnow joins us right now
tyler so first off what's randy saying
to you and do you think he's going to
win rookie of the year as margot swings
on one to short and bogarts with the
high throw dalbeck corrals it route
number one go ahead tyler
yeah you mentioned it earlier before we
got on you're saying i could chime in
and i was thinking of randy the whole
way
randy's my shoe in for a few of the year
what was he saying to you just now
i i had my my headphones on i didn't
even hear him i was like yeah yeah okay
sounds good
[Laughter]
sure also where do i look i got where am
i where are you all at where am i
looking so turn your head a little to
the left right field
there it is
yes somewhere there yeah right around
there all right all right so we're
squared up all right doesn't matter
we're good you're a camera pro already
tyler great to have you we'll mix in
some questions for our youtube creators
too so let's start with last night and
really your season as a whole first
couple starts but yesterday nine
strikeouts over six innings one run give
us your evaluation of your beginning to
the season
yeah it's been feeling good i worked on
a couple things in spring um it's been
awesome just being with kyle and kind of
being on that everyday program on
working with kind of like new
adjustments i'd say mechanically and
mentality and then obviously like with
the third pitch it's just been nice to
stay on that routine and like figure out
kind of how to execute it more
consistently so um i i mean i feel
really comfortable right now on the
mound
the last like five or so times i've
touched them out i've been i've been
feeling real good so hopefully i can
just kind of keep that momentum in
throughout the entire season can you
enlighten everyone watching on youtube
about that third pitch that's really
becoming a solid weapon right away in
this 2021 campaign
uh yeah uh i don't know what you'd like
to know specifically but i
was working on it in the offseason a
little bit and like kind of
farting around with some grips and
nothing really felt that comfortable and
then
i flew in early to florida to try and
work with kyle and it was like the first
bullpen we threw like he's just so good
at that and i think we had so much
stuff to look at as far as like the
graphs and like the agitronic camera so
i just had like so many tools i could
utilize to really trying to hone in on
like a grip and a feeling of it and
in a matter of like a bullpen or two i
was like okay i have like a pretty
average slider that i can go and and
like compete with and then that season
went on or a spring one on
oh yeah
as spring went on
uh
yeah
that's nice of him but yeah spring went
on
the grip changed a little bit and then i
was like kind of becoming more
comfortable with it and throwing it with
more confidence and i think now it's
it's a pitch that i'm really comfortable
with and i think
that my heater i'm equally as
comfortable throwing in kind of any
count so i just think it gives me more
options and keeps hitters away from just
kind of selling out and guessing
we also just showed your reaction time
on that foul ball well done wow that was
quick
tyler you're one of my favorite
interviews but
uh
we didn't get much time with you as
there's the strikeout of [ __ ] hernandez
or excuse me the strikeout on the other
side and uh we appreciate you joining us
tyler hopefully we can chat for longer
next time
yeah for sure next time you let me know
i'm here yes you're always here talk to
my people we'll figure it out
we'll set it up tyler thanks good luck
all right we'll talk soon yeah thank you
guys that's willy adams down on strikes
to end the inning native aldi
not letting it breathe much huh
two men on for jason bay
delta deep down on the field line into
the corner that ball is off the base of
the wall a two run double jason bay and
the red sox lead to nothing here is
longoria to try and make something
happen
here down the left-hand line it's got a
chance back towards the corner and evan
has tried it out swinging a drive into
deep left field going back his corporate
still going back that ball is gone
it is three to two red stops swinging a
drive deep left field
is this one gonna go it's way out of
here
[Applause]
another home run kevin youklis lining a
home run to tie it at five it's a home
run
six to five red sox
drive up to left for your line free lane
throw is not in time
that's over the catcher's glove quick
ricochet throw to the plate not in time
a wild pitch ties it up
there's a pop-up
under it is through he catches it
here comes the throw it's all fine and
the reigns have wanted
[Applause]
it's the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by fidelity scott
braun john smoltz carlos pena and alana
rizzo with you for the action this
afternoon let's flash back
to the fourth inning
and ryan yarbrough does a nice job of
wait the hesitation but let me cover
first john because that's my job when
suzugo picks up the baseball and he does
get the job done that's into a glove
sharply struck by dalbeck over the third
wendell makes the catch but
it gets me thinking and reminiscing to a
play from back in the day john do you
remember this yeah communication i tell
him i got it i got it stay there but
it's too late and then i'm trying to
make the play of the sentry
i was trying to tell julio franco that i
got it i'm like cat i'm a cat on the
mount and
what i thought was gonna happen and what
you just saw was totally opposite i
thought the bag was like two feet from
me and so i was gonna drop stop and roll
to the bag and make the greatest play
ever seen and unfortunately it's the
play that never goes away
and
after that the team had a lot of fun
with that on the charter flight home
they showed a video
for the fire department they wanted me
to use they wanted me to be their video
for drop stop and roll
so
it is what it is uh
it didn't make the play
and
it's a video for everyone to see what
not to do
he'll take first
john you're a great sport though
i try to be
your breakdown of that play is
excellent elite
this pitch missed and carlos this hurts
yeah i don't care how much armor you get
on that hits you in the funny bone and
you're gonna be complaining about that
for at least a week
but thank god for those shields right
there
still hurts
you can see pojacki shaking it off
earns the base here we are scott brown
john smoltz carlos pena alana rizzo at
the ballpark
and we have the top of the order for
boston in [ __ ] hernandez
bottom of the fifth inning boston
leading 3-1 thanks to christian pasquez
with a two-run shot over the green
monster
i'll tell you what scotty i think that
kika is going to be a huge addition for
the red sox
um he's going to see a lot more playing
time than with the dodgers he's going to
be all over the place and this is a
role that he embraces so i think he's
gonna blossom
uh over in boston and the fans are gonna
love him for it
alex cora was talking to us about [ __ ]
this morning and said
bigger than he was a few years ago
stronger knows his body and his game
more than ever he has been a huge fan of
[ __ ] for years and is really excited to
have him as the spark at the top of the
order he's never been a lead off hitter
but he looks like he can fill that role
quite well for boston
well the big key is going to be i mean
he's made it a swing change a couple
years ago and of course he's looking to
play pepper with that wall his new
friend will be that wall but can he can
he stay off of a change-ups and
off-speed pitch
to where that has been his kind of
kryptonite especially against lefties
kk loves dancing too
looks good playing out there
great personality man just a great
energy brings it every time to the
ballpark
one of those spark uh spark plugs uh
the proverbial spark plugs uh that he is
uh in that clubhouse is gonna do
more than we can quantify
and really the red sox look if you look
at the whole entire setup
they should be contending
it's like brady bunch on your screen
right now we've got one more alana rizzo
what can you add for us
well i can tell you that alex cora and
kiki hernandez have a very long history
together in a good relationship he calls
them enrique because of course that is
his first name but [ __ ] has been such a
good piece of the dodgers puzzle for the
last six years and i asked alex corey i
said
did you know what you were getting when
kiki came to the red sox he said you
know what he's a better player than the
one that he saw meaning alex in 2017 he
said defensively he's outstanding he
said you know what though it's been
really an eye-opener for me just how
good he is defensively an elite defender
an elite defender particularly at second
base he doesn't get a ton of reps in the
outfield but he says his defense out
there is just as stellar as it is on the
infield and he said he's really just a
great addition to the club
and an addition that contributes at the
plate
base hit he could be gay
he can hit plawecky over his
i don't know if he was sitting on that
pitch but he made an adjustment on that
pitch we talked about the changeup that
gave him fits you know he's got an
uppercut type swing so the fastball is
something he's not bothered by but watch
where he goes down it's a pitcher's
pitch i mean you take that aggressive
full
throttle swing he misses that so kudos
to him and making the adjustment and
getting that pitcher's pitch
rewarded for a hit
pitching coach kyle snyder out to talk
things over with ryan yarbrough
hernandez from puerto
just like his manager alex cora who is
the gm for puerto rico in the 2017 world
baseball classic
[ __ ] played on that team
you know what else stands out go ahead
carlos you wonder what what
the conversation is like at the
on the mound because multi sometimes i
think when pitchers get hit we
immediately say oh maybe he missed his
spot maybe it was a mistake
but not really sometimes it's just good
hitting beating good pitching and just
as
it is important to understand when you
make a mistake it's it is also important
to understand when
you just got beat
if you're going to be a good pitcher you
have to know the difference corrects
multi absolutely
this is an action pitch right here
should be a first pitch fastball
that's the hard stuff from yarburo
well the thing is you know you you get
reminded from your pitching coach like
hey no big deal we're going to get a
double play right here you're pitching
fine and no one that's not with the
exception of the home run there hasn't
been a bunch of balls rocking it all
over
and you just need a general reminder
to reset the brain i call it the
computer because it can get a virus in
there in the middle of the game when you
start thinking negatively or thinking
differently than the game plan you had
going in
stick to the code
yeah
that's a swing that evers wanted back
boston started this game two for ten at
the plate in the first three innings
against yarborough they've been cracking
the code lately
three for their last seven
contributing to those three runs
blocky was hit by a pitch he's in
scoring position now and tk hernandez
following with a base hit
one one to devers
sent to center
playable for margot
starts drifting in
two gone in the fifth
let's bring in statcast 3d powered by
google cloud
rafael devers still so young so talented
so powerful
and he uses this ballpark carlos
he does i mean he has this
angle when he steps slightly into the
bucket with his stride that allows him
to let the ball travel and he hits the
ball the other way as you can see off of
the monster and he uses that wall to his
advantage
he is tailored made for fenway park and
that is precisely i
see him being a pillar of this
organization as far as offensive
numbers are concerned offensive
production is concerned for years to
come and he's still 24 years old that is
hard to believe with all the success
he's already had
yeah 24 and
we're talking about bobby bobby dalbeck
who's barely seen big league time but
has serious power potential he's older
than devers he's 25.
a lot accomplished
by the red sox third baseman already
so he was the second out now it's jd
hitless this afternoon
but off to a 10-23 start
two homers five doubles
and he gives that ball a ride
deep left will it stay fair
and it's high off the wall
and it'll score a couple runs for boston
plowecki comes in so does hernandez
and jd martinez has himself a run
scoring double it's 4-1 boston
he was slightly early on this pitch
right here but he was able to keep that
barrel
in the zone for long enough to get in
good contact with the baseball with that
short wall he takes advantage of it but
look how he it's out in front slightly
but he's able to have that long through
the zone back path just missing a home
run
there he is making an impact great start
5-1 2 score for boston jd martinez
attacking the green monster successfully
11 rbis on the season already for jd
playing in his sixth game of the season
boston checking in at two and three on
the year
swept by baltimore they've taken the
first two against tampa bay and
they're in good shape right now in the
fifth
against the defending al champs
tampa bay at two wins and three losses
as well
and it doesn't get any easier scotty i
mean here's sander bogart and we were
talking about how he since 2015
one of the best shore stops in the game
we're talking about batting average
since 2015 he's first ranking first in
the big leagues runs first extra base
hits second only to lindor
and rbi's
first as well and three silver slugger
awards in that span i mean we're really
watching one of the one of the game's
greats uh as of right now in that
position
a couple all-star appearances
consistently great
for boston plays every day
and his teammate is the first player in
red sox history with an extra base hit
in his first six games of the season
making up for what he calls a lost year
in 2020 at the plate well you know what
a lot of us want to forget 2020.
absolutely
three runs in the fourth two more in the
fifth
five total for boston
martinez on second after driving in two
bogart's seeking his third hit of the
day
[Music]
giraffe neck mark said jd standing for
just doubles today
you know i missed this
yeah didn't everybody i mean even the
players you know just such a welcome and
it's hopefully going to get better as
time goes on in each stadium
some fans are going wait you miss ryan
yarborough taking his time and taking
too long yeah i miss the roar of the
crowd especially in boston
here comes that one too
oh guards didn't go
well the fans are like the soundtrack of
the baseball game i mean you could just
see
how things an intense moment you can
hear the crowd the crescendo they get
behind you also i love watching the
reaction when a ball is hit well and
goes towards the outfield and they're
anticipating perhaps a home run i love
the way they they get up and cheer i
mean i really truly miss that as a fan
watching and i can only imagine how much
the players missed it
2-2 on the ground nice stop but adamus
dropped the baseball
martinez safe at third bogarts gets to
first
backhand pick by adamus was strong but
second half of the play the exchange
didn't happen
i'm a first guesser and i'm a pitcher
but this still has to be a hit this was
absolutely smoked and you see the hop
eats him up it would have taken a great
throw and a good play so we'll see how
it's it's scored but
two strike hitting keeping the inning
alive
red sox
starting to show a little bit of their
old self when they were a
crooked number machine meaning they
could put up a crooked number in any one
of those nine innings
did they rule anything yet
as soon as i receive it
it's coming at you should be a hit it
should be a hit i'm with you that ball
was smoked scorched
pick your verb
yes
hey look at this start by christian
vasquez you know i was just thinking
about how
good of a starter i was or if i had
really bad aprils i think in my career i
was not typically a good starter man it
was tough to dig yourself out of a hole
when you start off slow but when you see
these guys in the 400s with two home
runs already and we're just a few games
into the season boy that must feel great
it's a great
spark to get your season going
he did this last year too vazquez with a
sizzling first week of the season
and now drops one into shallow left and
that'll score another one for boston
jd come on down it's 6-1
he got fisted of this swing right here
but he was able to push it through
keeping that level switching the zone
gives you a little bit more margin for
error
i believe this is gonna be
uh that cutter
it does jam him
but that level swing through the zone
allows him to push this baseball over
the infielders in the line drive
trajectory
and good hitters do that they don't
notify the swing if they're off timing
that was just uh
right there you got to tip your hat
good hitting
jd martinez and christian vasquez
all the talk in boston so far this
season four home runs
slugging off the charts
waiting for the rest of the group to
catch up
like hunter renfro for two today
broke his back
serves one up here for adamus
and the throw skips away
and bogarts comes home it's 7-1
and here comes another it's vasquez
racing around they go
key mishap
from tampa bay on defense
and it opens this one up
you're not going to see this too often
it's about as routine as it gets
the batter has no real foot speed that
created any stress this is a jam
ground ball to a good sure-handed
shortstop
and he just takes his time and the ball
just goes straight down
and maybe maybe
a tough play on both ends to try to
expect the first baseman should come up
with that because it was wide of the bag
but the day that ended last night and
the momentum
for the red sox you could argue is
carried forward into this short
turnaround game this afternoon
alana what else can you tell us about
that last play
well guys just a couple of defensive
miscues here by the tampa bay rays and
we all had the conversation earlier
today with ray's manager kevin cash
about how important it is for his ball
club to be able to defend the baseball
when it is in play he said with the
altered baseball in this season we
figure to have fewer home runs or balls
in the air he said you absolutely have
to catch the baseball we must defend and
not have sloppy plays with the glove
alana while we have you
what's the scene like out there too
um it's awesome you guys are just
talking about the crowd and whether
they're cheering for you or jeering
against you it's so nice to have a fan
base albeit at a small capacity back in
the ballpark they make such a huge
difference and the players absolutely
thrive off of having them back
and the fans are loving this inning for
boston christian arroyo delivers and
scores another for the red sox to make
it 9-1
i could continue on the fan thing that
port
[Applause]
and guys just to continue on about the
fan experience when i was talking to
alex cora earlier today i joked with him
i said i understand you got off to an
early start he stopped me in my tracks
he said alana there is no early start
when you play in boston he said we know
where we live we know where we played we
know the expectations of this fan base
he said you know what it's actually a
good learning experience for the new
guys the the new members of this boston
red sox club that perhaps haven't played
in a in an atmosphere or with an
expectation from a fan base like this he
said you know what it reminds us they're
going to be loud he said my job as a
manager is to keep the dugout and the
clubhouse quiet
[Music]
and the fans are loud and feeling it
after a six-run inning continues yeah
you got a feel for mr yarbor he has not
given up a lot of ton of hard hit balls
in the last couple but
many would question why he's still out
there well the extra innings in the long
season he has a ton of pitches
it's just a tough one to swallow when
you're on the bad end of a 9-1 and
you're still in the game
you're trying to get that last out and
reset the game for whoever's going to
come in next
bobby dalbeck started this inning a
million years ago
lining out to joey wendell colin mchugh
looks like he'll follow ryan yarbrough
be curious to see
[Applause]
what type of exit velocities
these hits have produced because like
sports was saying
not a lot of hard hit balls
in this inning
but baseball is interesting how
sometimes momentum shifts and
after last night's game
you know just seemed like
the red sox everything is going their
way
[Applause]
it's tough to give anybody six outs
in an inning
five outs you could
say has been
recorded in this inning but the third
out hasn't officially been made
see if it happens here dalbeck
is retired that ends the inning six runs
for boston i think the red sox account
in the chat right now
put it well
confirmed we're having a good time
indeed
so with two out and one out here is the
owner of our navarro 295 during the
regular season now the pitch is swinging
round a second heading for the plate and
scoring is longoria navarro is out but
the rays are on the scoreboard that's
well there's a high drive deep into left
center field way back there and it's
over everything a three run homer for
upton four nothing tampa bay
two two count
driven left center field and deep as
well that one's got a chance to go and
it does
and longoria extends the tampa bay lead
now five to nothing with one out in the
eighth the rays lead five to one and
here's rocco buldelli there's a swing
and there's a high drive to left field
that one is way back there that ball is
gone and the reigns have busted the game
open in the eighth inning here's a swing
by pena and a high drive deep into left
center field that one is way back there
that one is still going it's gone
three two pitch swinging a fly ball left
field back goes crawford at the edge of
the track he has it and this one is over
the final tampa bay nine the red sox won
the rays lead the series two games to
one
[Music]
what'd they give they give that hit
it'd be three for three if it's a hit
bulgaris was a hit
new to the mlb game of the week for the
2021 season is the youtube player of the
game fans watching on mobile devices and
computers can vote for which player will
receive a trophy during the post game
show so stay tuned
we'll have polling options later in the
show oh this is our first look at the
trophy that's nice
that almost looks
too good to be true that's amazing job
look at the architecture to put that
together john what do you think trophy
yeah add it someone's gonna add it right
yeah and you'll keep it
it's not digital it's actually physical
that's right almost looked digital
perfectly done by youtube
as we're bringing it here digitally
today to a global audience
that is a physical trophy that will be
handed out after the game
i'm gonna make
a very educated prediction and say that
trophy will probably land in the hands
of a boston red sox player it's a good
prediction so far i like to play it safe
very bold
thanks lois
see how the rays respond here in the
sixth
long long break
for native aldi
before he steps back up he's only 66
pitches into his outing though very
rewarding break you know that if a team
is going to take that long to score that
you're given room for error and that you
just have to mentally check back in as
quick as you can when you get on the
mound
six runs off five hits one error and a
hit by pitch
all in that fifth it's a learn trait
people say all the time hey pitch like
it's one to nothing well you know it's
not one to nothing it's now nine to one
you have to train yourself to
i call it white noise to not pay
attention to say if you go out to the
mound and go i've got room for three
errors now you know i can make three
mistakes then you're in trouble but you
try your best to go out there and get
the fir i always thought when a team
scored me five runs or more or it was a
long inning the first hitter i don't
care what happened to second hitter the
first hitter was going to be made and
out that was my
only objective and then you go piece it
together after that
so that means a big pitch coming up for
evaldi here
for him personally yeah one game he'll
be okay yeah it's interesting he stayed
away from the velocity aspect with this
guy based on the information that
everybody gets to see
there it is
climbs the ladder
to put away to tugo
alana what do you have
well another k for evalda you guys and
coming off of his opening day outing or
his first outing of this season he said
he had a good mix of the repertoire and
really alex corrie just said you know
what it's a bit of a tough luck loss for
him considering the lack of run support
he received in his first outing he was
hoping today that of aldi could give him
about 100 110 pitches six or seven
innings right now just sitting at
a very efficient 69 on the pitch count
so doing exactly what his manager was
hoping for
yeah he's retired six in a row
four of those hitters via strikeout
now austin meadows bringing it and he'll
grunt sometimes so you heard that
there's no doubt look the one thing that
he's been able to do over the last
couple innings is start guys off with
curveballs you see the arsenal cutter
curveball splitter that curveball is
such a break in the tension of speed for
a hitter that's why he could throw that
almost at will for strikes it may not be
his wipeout pitch with two strikes but
he gets ahead with it
and that's ship to center [ __ ] hernandez
is going to play that off the wall
bare-handed
and that's a double for meadows
kiki's just have it forming there's
nobody on and he's trying
trying to deak like he might have had
that bald effectively
the runner that's not going to change
his mind he knows as soon as he hit that
ball
you know as when we came in as the
national team we of course didn't hit
but every pitcher wanted to take bp to
just see what was that wall like and how
a easily it was it reachable
and what did you have to do to to launch
it over the wall to get a home run
when i took bp here i was so
disappointed
because i realized as a pitcher the
hitter has a tremendous advantage with
that wall that i stopped taking bp
because i didn't want that to be in my
head when i went out to the mound and
ironically i as a visiting pitcher
you mentioned the top of the hour how i
played for the red sox although be it
short
i did not give up an earned run and
think
in 29 innings as a visiting pitcher
against that lineup because they struck
fear into you
i undid that so fast as a home pitcher i
might have given up 29 runs
in a short period of time but i tried to
use that visitor mindset like hey i've
had success here that'll work
well
it didn't so
i wish it were different uh
come to find out
to make matters worse when i went to st
louis and finished my career there
i was tipping my pitches
which does not help the problem when
you're giving up
a lot of runs and hits
rosarina
just as frustrated as you there
john
scott barry the home plate umpire with
the call there he went around
yes he did but as i learned about this
organization even though it was short
the rich history is phenomenal the way
they
treat every player as a family is
phenomenal
and the the crowd and the fan base loves
their red sox and we talked earlier
about even with
alex cora about getting on the wrong
side
if you will is not a fun place to be in
boston getting on the right side is a
euphoric place to be because they will
love you to death if you're putting in
the time the effort and the results of
course
hugs free beverages all of that all
around the city
i'm going to share one quick story and i
know it's it's it's a broadcaster's
she's not supposed to do this with two
outs i got there my first week was
my car in a parking lot was packed with
all my stuff going to pawtucket i read a
sign on the door says you should not be
parking where you're parking go back it
was up on the tow truck in three minutes
this guy was ready to take my car and
everything away and i was trying to get
his attention he would have nothing of
it he was
can't you read and i'm taking your car
well i mentioned pawtucket i said i have
to get to pawtucket tomorrow and his
head turned around he goes are you with
the red sox
i said yes sir i am my car was down we
were best of friends within five minutes
and i got to retrieve all my stuff but
it was about to start really bad for my
uh
short career there in boston
sir john smoltz here hall future hall of
famer i didn't want a name drop and i
didn't but i was worried like can he
physically take me in the car with my
stuff on the tow truck i was getting in
the car
that's a great story
that's paul ford allow on four pitches
when we had when he went home and and
realized who you were he probably was
kicking himself like what in the world
did i just embarrass myself
he was doing his job i just i couldn't
believe how quickly he was doing his job
like it was literally five minutes
efficient he wasn't he was efficient
he was going to impact the red sox i was
done i would have had no idea what to do
i had everything that i owned at that
time that was going to be in boston in
that i had a suburban and i
it was it was so shocking
but then we're leaving afterwards to
be able to go to put pawtucket and
start my rehab
saved by the socks
two on for yandy diaz and ivaldi blows
98 right past him
nice and easy too it's so effortless you
know has definitely got a lot of power
behind that fastball
and a lot of us sometimes even wonder
i'm like wow you know ivaldi's got the
stuff to be elite elite in the league
um and i thought he's mixed his pitches
extremely well if he continues to do so
he's going to have a good year yeah the
key carlos for him is of course for
every pitcher it's healthy but if his
hand deviates at all to the tilt side of
on the side of the ball his 98 doesn't
mean 98 when he stays on the ball even
though it's a low three quarter then the
extra hop and it can vary from pitch to
pitch it's a mechanical key that he is
trying to work on when he stays behind
the ball there's nobody that throws it
like he does like that
99.
spots it up
retires diaz strikes out the side in the
sixth seven
on the day
for eval
fenway parked the site for game four the
rays have won the last two games of this
series putting up big offensive numbers
in that stretch
now the pitch we're gonna drive towards
the monster and left center field back
to the ball goes bay looking up and pena
has hit it out and right away the rays
take a two-nothing lead
[Applause]
now longoria drives one deep left that
one's gonna go back-to-back bombs for
the raise
the crowd which was quieted early last
night is quieted again here in the top
of the first
there's a high drive down the left field
line very deep on its way that ball is
gone
whoa what a shot
and a raised lead grows to five nothing
here at fenway
[Music]
it is ten to one tampa bay
well you can bet the red sox are glad
there's an off day tomorrow
line drive another hit ibarr has a five
rbi night tonight
one two pitch good night swinging amidst
strike three and the rays have taken a
three games to one lead in the american
league championship series
so
[Applause]
is
[Music]
the great randy rosarina miked up today
do you want me to take this or should we
go to carlos
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay hey carlos can you translate john's
still thinking about it
yeah that was pretty cool i mean he was
talking about
the fact that he has no clue of that
ball the one that was down in foul
territory got into his glove he just
went after it and then he's talking to
williams saying what happened i mean i
thought that if i got underneath the
ball
and
and i had it then we're okay and adam
was saying no no someone touched it so
it does not count and he was just
perplexed like what do you mean i was
underneath that ball and i caught it
john that's what you were going to say
right i was going to say i was going to
say basically i i understand the letter
of the rule i just don't conceptually
understand how that can't be an outcome
yeah i'm with you
it was entertaining it was skilled
jd came back out
and yar bar still got the job done but
later faltered
against boston
collins
in there now buys that road by the way
guys right i think we should
we should i mean
it just does not seem fair
colin mchugh is is the
again on the opposite spectrum of
yarbrough
the right-hander who can spin the ball
and create deception he doesn't have an
exertion that looks like he's emptying
the tank but he knows how to pitch spin
it located he's coming back from some
injuries of course he had time with the
astros and some success there with
teaching him how to spin the baseball
and his ability to spin it is
really good
and he has a lot in his arsenal too for
seam fastball cutter curveball changeup
sinker slider i know we fall in love
with the output of information of what
spin rate means but i'm of the mindset
like i couldn't teach you how to throw
my slider spin rate i could teach you
how to throw my slider what comes
naturally to a pitcher is a gift
and and some guys have been able to
improve and and get the velocity i can
teach anybody to throw a ball harder
whether or not that translates to
success for them is going to be based on
their athleticism and their mechanics
but spinning a baseball and changing
directions is not not everybody can do
it if everybody could do it they'd all
have similar type pitches
but the technology that we have to try
to emulate and simulate those things are
phenomenal i mean that
never existed you know
the trevor bowers of the world that
basically have been able to
inundate himself with all that
information and transform him
into a pitcher that has now four or five
pitches whereas
15 years ago you be what you are you
know
yeah it worked for mchugh i mean he
didn't really pan out with the mets and
then a waiver claimed by the astros they
said hey why don't you stick with more
of that spin yeah and it really made his
career
get exclusive content and highlights
from your favorite team the tampa bay
race head on over to youtube.com raise
and hit that subscribe button today
raise fans there's your spot youtube.com
race
sends one deep to left
and that is
caught
austin meadows to the track makes the
catch
one gone you know what's amazing about
our game whether it's on the hitting
side of the pitching side when somebody
opens up a door for you and what they
mean is opens up a venue for success or
a thought process you wouldn't think
it changes certain guys career i'll
never forget throwing the way we were
taught to throw you never threw a what's
called a front door slider to a
right-handed hitter when i learned how
to do that it was so incredibly
life-changing that you throw out some of
the theories based on
the time frame you're pitching in when
you throw you know lefties used to never
throw a lefty on lefty change up or
righties used to never throw when you
start evolving as a player and see what
certain
teams or philosophy can give you a
chance for success it changes
hernandez hot shot past the infield and
he's aboard
back-to-back base hits for [ __ ]
hernandez
after a no for two start
that's twice already they'd i've seen
kiki hernandez
the previous at-bat hitting an off-speed
pitch and then right here all over this
lighter and small mentioned that perhaps
he was sitting on the changeup in the
previous at-bat he was certainly sitting
on this ladder he did not look fooled at
all even though like we were talking
about it it's a very devastating one but
when you know that it's coming and you
get ready for it you get healthy swings
like that one yeah especially if it's in
the wrong location where it stayed
middle middle like that one did
i've heard you know
i've heard you hitters talk about carlos
how sometimes it can be dangerous when
you sit on a pitch that means you're
sitting on a pitch you see it you think
you have to swing there's a difference
between sitting on a pitch and getting
it in the spot you want that's totally
different than just
seeing it and automatically thinking you
have to swing
that is absolutely right and that is why
when you are sitting on a pitch you got
to have a trajectory in mind you have to
visualize
where does this ball need to start in
order for me to offer at it well if it's
that's lighter it certainly has to start
maybe letter high most definitely above
your waist otherwise it should be an
automatic take
devers just found that ball off his leg
i can honestly say
however many hits or however many
at-bats i've had i was never good enough
to follow a ball off my body and i'm
sure carlos you have plenty of examples
of what that feels like
in spanish we call it a dog bite it
feels like a like a dog pretty much just
bit a big piece off of your leg uh it
hurts like crazy and right now you see
him back in in the box but that thing is
throbbing
up the middle but nowadays there's often
a man there
endeavors is retired
so colin mchugh comes on and does his
job for tampa bay huge day for boston
though double digit hits for a third
consecutive game
9-1 socks
knocks the defending world champions are
teetering on the brink of elimination
tonight
swing and a high fly ball hammered left
field bj upton hits another home run
the power surge for the raise continues
and now it is five to nothing for the
third game in a row here at fenway the
reigns have five on the board by the
third inning
dj has had a coming out party in this
lcs
that one is off the monster it's a
double corrupted
and the reyes may be finishing off the
red sox to the seventh inning
dumps it into right field for a base hit
red sox finally get on the board
ortiz hits the high fly ball right field
it'll come down with a three-run home
run
swing and drive
[Applause]
3-1
can you believe it
[Applause]
we're back in boston red sox up big time
for our next poll question which player
has the best dance moves two rays in the
mix rosarina and brett phillips who both
put on a show in the playoffs last year
a dance-off show basically and [ __ ]
hernandez is on this list so is andrew
mccutchen who has smooth moves well this
is a good one i want to see if we can
impact the boat too so
john you're going to have to make a
selection i want an early pick carlos
you first actually give us a pick and
then let's see how things go in about an
inning from now when we get the results
i'm gonna have to go with rosarina i
mean you just saw an earlier piece we
did in today's
show
and he was just breaking it down scotty
so i think he most definitely has
the best dance moves in the league
here's kevin prado who debuted yesterday
called up for kevin kiermeier who's on
the shelf
smolty your selection yeah that's
got to go same same pick yeah
there he is
he's got the hairdo to go along with it
just not a lot of
no reason to dance just yet
with a 9-1 deficit
looking to change things here
the case right there it just that pitch
was on the hitter so fast i don't even
think he had a chance to swing at it and
that'll be viewed as a good take
i would question
i just don't think he had a chance
and he works a walk
all right so let's run through our
candidates
andrew mccutchen
let's break it down the veteran
give us the breakdown carlos
yeah kiki right here
it's they're very peculiar moves
and arrows arena it's a little bit more
you know even wraps to it you know he's
got some lyrics behind that dance i i
just think that rosarina brings more to
the equation
kike's circular motion
uh i'm not a big fan of that
um and the one giving them a good
competition it has to be mccutchen oh
what a play that's mike brasso bouncing
into two
that's a bigger pitch than uh
we're gonna give credit for he's at 90
right and that double play
with two outs in the seventh actually
gives him an opportunity to pitch the
eighth
fairly easy and talking to alex cora
that would be a dream scenario even
though it's early in the in the year
uh
the pitching staffs of baseball are
going to be used at the highest rate
ever i think this year because of the
fear of last year's short season and the
unknown who's going to be able to pitch
innings this year
now mejia
weak ground ball
look at native aldi
excellent day
first pitching in a tight game
now it's all red sox and he still has
his a plus stuff this afternoon
boston nine tampa bay one let's stretch
the rays and the boston red sox get
ready to play game number six of the
american league championship series
red sox in game six they've been pretty
good in these situations in the past
and swims and he crutches one high and
beats the left set field it hits the
catwalk
one
[Applause]
ground ball up the middle they make the
play at first but roya scores red sox
take a 2-1 lead
swinging
[Applause]
jason bartman has tied the
game veritech gets it on a line to right
center field it is back at the wall it's
gone
swing live live in the right center
field that's in there base hit
it's 4-2 boston
[Applause]
there's a game seven tomorrow night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by fidelity we're
infidelity we're in fenway park it's the
red sox all over the rays today
finishing up a three-game series boston
going for the sweep and red sox fans
this is for you for an inside look at
the socks
check out youtube.com
red socks be sure to subscribe for all
of the latest videos
martinez bogart's vasquez do up for the
sox
colin mchugh back to work in the seventh
jd with a healthy dose of doubles so far
this season about a week's worth of
games
you know you can't say this for every
team and every player but i really felt
coming into the start of this first 10
to 14 games it was essential for the red
red sox to have a good feeling about
their first 14 games and boy oh boy
after going 0-3
in their first three you could just
start to hear
what the season was going to be like
what they're writing about and the
pressure and all the things this
turnaround is is is huge
for the red sox not for every team
because every team can rely on their
balance and strength of their roster the
red sox are going to have to piece this
thing together from a pitching
standpoint all year offensively i think
they're going to be okay
so
i can i've been in too many clubhouses
where you sense like hey we got to win
this game and someone said it's only
game seven
like no we gotta turn it around because
the
the feeling you have leaving spring
training and the feeling you had last
year was not a good one
from a red sox nation standpoint and
from a player personnel
yeah it's not like the dodgers and the
dodgers didn't start out well you'd be
like okay whatever they'll be fine
there's joseph odom by the way new
catcher
in for mejia
and like the rays the rays as we talked
about during this game are built for 26
plus players to get through the year
because they're built on a system
that has to rely on more pieces because
financially they're not in the
neighborhood of some of the other clubs
well the red sox i don't want to say
it's a total rebuild because that's not
the case
but you look at where they came from and
where they are now it's this total shell
of themselves from a pitching standpoint
so they have to find some diamonds
interrupt they're gonna have to find
some performances that they didn't see
coming
for them to be competitive all year in a
division that has
arguably gotten better this year with
what the rays did last year what the
jays did in the off season
it is a popular topic of discussion when
you think about the lower
that's cordero bullet to right field and
fielded out of bounds by brasso who just
recently checked into the game
and francie cordero contributes a single
we have another mic'd up player he's the
man who's about to step up christian
vazquez
[Applause]
that one john you know what i can
translate i'm so scared to death of
those elbow punt those elbow things oh
ever since cody every time i see it i'm
like
there's some big strong donkeys that
take they would take my shoulder right
off
it did to cody ballinger yeah in the
playoffs
separated his shoulder
and vasquez didn't say much on that
except for vamos let's go
but i think the one thing that it's
universal i mean every language
understands this is the crack of the bat
right
that was loud
period
perfect translation as usual carlos
indeed you could translate spanish
baseball bat
oh yeah i know how to speak that
language yes you do and you did it well
for many years my favorite
cordero on for vazquez by the way
you're gonna get a lot more of that
audio
here's your teaser john on a show called
play loud that's coming soon to youtube
all of those players miked up all the
good stuff fans always saying what did
he say there what did he say there
you're gonna get a lot more of that on
youtube so stay tuned not for this game
but stay tuned keep an eye on mlb's
youtube channel
i was miked up
in the
champions tour us open that i briefly
played in yeah how did that go i didn't
go good uh or well uh at all for me but
i wanted to give a perspective honestly
just people who sit at home like a
thousand people saying oh i could have
shot that i could have done that no you
couldn't
and no you won't but it was uh
a lot of the uh
players on the tour actually asked me
suggested i i shouldn't do it i said
listen
i really don't have a chance to make the
cut this is an unbelievable experience
of my life one of the biggest thrills of
my lifetime and i just really want to be
able to give to people what it's like
when you're playing in golf because we
don't get a lot of sports are starting
to get more integrated with technology
and you can hear that kind of bantering
the talk between you and your caddy
strikes out and obviously being on tv i
knew which lines were going to get on tv
and which weren't but i was sincere i
wasn't trying to make them up for the
sake of that
and i can remember the one time
just
i ran into bogey after bogey after bogey
and i said to my caddy i cannot believe
the manager's leaving me in this game
what are they thinking
how could they not bring in the lefty or
take but in golf you you just don't get
to come out it's all on you that's why
you love the game though i do love it
well the manager probably left you in
because he knows it can get worse for
example if that if that would have been
me it would probably would have been
bogey double bogey bogey double bogey
he's like all right we'll leave small
tin for sure no problem
yeah for carlos or me they might have
kicked us off the course eventually so
that would be our manager pulling us
from the game you know honestly what i
learned from that and i never
experienced this in my baseball career i
can honestly say i was never nervous to
the point of not being able to swallow
or spit or feel like i couldn't perform
in baseball
i stood on that first tee and it was
just anxiousness of of things that i
knew i wasn't as talented
or in that arena that i was in and i
said for the first time if i can now
appreciate what other players or
athletes feel like when they're out of
their element when you're out of your
element in your comfort zone it causes a
breathing problem it causes an execution
problem
and the next thing you know you're
having to talk yourself into certain
things and so it was a valuable teaching
lesson for me even though my playing
career was done
i was so thankful that didn't happen to
me as a player
and and
as a you know for whatever it's worth
whatever i can play in golf it'll serve
me better the next time i'm in that
situation
renfro broke his bat nice stop by
tatsugo and mchugh covers
for the out
that'll do it for the seventh
and the red sox
have more scoring
against tampa bay today
here's pedro
[Applause]
so it will be boston left-hander lester
who is truly one of the league's best
when he is on and he takes care of payne
nine up nine down for john lester
here's matt garza for the raid got him
swinging on a fastball and matt garzon
has struck
[Applause]
for boston in the eighth inning two outs
the season on the line in the hands of
david price what spots to put this young
man
and the red sox lead the base is loaded
in the eighth inning
chad lowry the final hope for boston in
the ninth
ground ball to second iwamero's gun
razor going to the world series
[Applause]
we welcome you back to fenway park and
nike and several mlb clubs have come
together for city connect jerseys and we
all know a couple of times a couple last
year they've been able to do the
players weekend jerseys and now a
different element in terms of being able
to connect with your city it's developed
in partnership with mlb club's nike mlb
city connect series celebrates the bond
between each club and its city these are
the ones that the boston red sox are
going to be wearing on patriots day over
of course the boston marathon weekend
and it's just actually they've postponed
it this year because of cove it's
supposed to be in october if they are
actually able to run the marathon but
the inaugural season of these mlb city
connect will feature seven clubs right
now the diamondbacks the red sox which
you're looking at right now the cubs the
white sox the dodgers the marlins and
the giants and hopefully
over the course of the next couple of
years all of the teams will have these
city connect jerseys kyle looks a little
bit like boston red sox and ucla guys
yeah lana i'm thinking about the boyle
boylston street finish line
gold
and blue
unique
and there are a lot of nooks and
crannies to
this uni as well the 617 area code here
we go uh poor carlos we'll mail you one
okay
yeah thank you guys i'm i'm feeling so
left out those are beautiful
they look really cool i love the hats
too
yeah i'm partial to hats for a lot of
reasons
[Laughter]
really well done though
here's your 617
yep
area code
you know carlos
that's a lot of your childhood in the
area yep yes
but also it's the finish line sketch
feel to boston too
yeah holding it up well
that'd i do
does have the ucla feel
which are great colors very unique
colors to baseball too it's funny i was
just talking to buck showalter the other
day about unique baseball uniform colors
and those were two of the colors we
brought out you don't see a lot of
yellow and you don't see a lot of that
shade of blue so to see that combination
is unique and it has ties to the iconic
weekend
in boston with patriots day coming up
clever creative i love it
you can grab those
on sale soon
it's amazing going through my
when you sell your house you go through
everything that you acquire you can
acquire more than you ever need
but i went through my memorabilia room
and
i just forgot i mean 21 years is a long
time but i forgot how many different
jerseys i pitched it like the amount of
jerseys and throwbacks and
all the different
styles that you know i mean now it's now
it's
it's not like you pitched for a million
teams no no i'm just talking about with
the atlanta braves it was
adamus
easy fly ball for jd martinez in right
field moving over across the outfield
now
we have a
poll result coming your way best dance
moves [ __ ] hernandez wins you know
boston wow showing up in a big way on
the pole
boston players dominating so is their
team
alana you covered [ __ ] hernandez for
years with the dodgers
would he take your vote as well
i mean i can only say yes because i
spent the last six years uh covering him
as far as his dance moves and his
shenanigans in the dugout often time i
would be doing my pre-game pre-first
pitch hit and he'd behind me doing all
of these different shenanigans he is
absolutely a character there used to be
dance offs between he and yasi opuig so
you had the puerto rican in the cube and
going at it in the dugout um yes i don't
i can't say the other three are not good
i haven't had as much experience
covering those uh those dance moves
yeah [ __ ] steals the show sometimes
literally
jumping on screen when you least expect
him he's fun
he's versatile susugo
to first that's for dalbeck
[Music]
pitcher wanted no part of that so that's
what it's their first basement yeah
this is josh taylor in relief of native
aldi
that's a look at your
defensive setup and the shift is on
and they've really switched things up in
the outfield martinez from left to right
cordero's in the game and left and
renfro playing center
still with that same infield
to start the day arroyo at second
dolbeck at first and you're usual on the
left side oh [ __ ] hernandez at short
yeah and that's where the red sox are
going to have to get used to positioning
and playing defense a little bit better
than they're used to because they had an
outfield not too long ago that was as
good as anybody's and none of those guys
are here so when you're talking about jd
playing outfield renfro playing outfield
he's got a cannon but the but the the
park other than
in colorado i don't think there's a more
important part to play defense outfield
wise than fenway there's so much room
from center to right now left is its own
problem that it'll be very interesting
to see how alex cora navigates that part
of their club
and whether that translates into some of
their success or failure based at the
end of the year
and you think back to 2018 when they won
it all and they had three center
fielders out there
and i you know people used to always say
and they say today if you had to draft a
right fielder between aaron judge and
mookie betts back in the day and i said
it totally depends on where they're
playing because i'm taking
i'm taking mookie betts and fenway but
i'm also taking aaron judge
in yankee stadium because mookie bets
and yankee stadiums
the impact's not the same
[Applause]
bobby dalbeck's making a name for
himself at first base
a vacuum
and a one two three inning for josh
taylor to sit down the side in order
[Applause]
oh he is hanging tough what are that bad
going here the swings against the
fastball get better and better for
brussels 3-2 brasso sends one into left
field gardner going back and it is up
and gone
mike
[Applause]
here is a shot into right center field
this ball is
[Applause]
and the all-time record for home runs in
a single post season with number nine
that ball was tattooed
jansen a strike away
the one-two pitch
and phillips has cashed in a base hit
back up the middle here's carefire to
score the ball's mishandled
and now they've got a rundown and
rosarito
won the game
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
who do you think will dominate the 2021
season make your picks and compete to
win 50 000
with mlb
season pick them see rules and enter at
mlb.com
and download the mlb app to get in-game
video highlights live pitch by pitch
breaking news player updates stat
leaderboards and much more
gotta love the app
and it's our first game of the season
live on youtube were presented by
fidelity today
scott brown john smoltz carlos pena and
alana rizzo with you this afternoon
boston well on their way
to sweep city
of a very talented tampa bay team
after being swept by the orioles to open
up their season that's baseball no it is
but that's also how delicate
the mental side of this game can be
because of the twists and turns and just
the narrative changes i i used to laugh
about opening week every year
talk radio you know i mean you come out
and you the greatest team i've ever seen
or this team's done like you can't make
any definitive statement until 21 days
to a month
that's who you become in 30 days
that's the team you're going to be
it's rare that you have these unless
they make a bunch of changes but this is
what i always think and i'd like to hear
carlos think as a former player too you
leave spring training you know you you
know the warts of your team you know
everything about your team and you just
hope they don't get exposed early enough
to people go oh oh
and so the the combat of
the teams that are the best are the ones
that have the least deficiencies and
they they can cover them
but during that whole run that we had we
knew one thing was constant we're gonna
outpitch you
and can we play a good enough defense
score enough runs so i always think that
that break between spring training and
the regular season the identity of your
team what is it does it improve does it
get exposed
[Applause]
yeah it's one of those things that you
know exactly where your strengths and
weaknesses are in a long season 162
games
if you have weaknesses they will be
exposed for sure you know and with the
race they're going to have to wheel and
deal they're going to have to utilize
their
26 players
this ball
flies that to left yep
and you know when you look at the way
that they
go about their business business it's
just trying to be cost effective it's a
low market team if you consider the race
they declined charlie morton's 50
million dollar option
you know but they signed chris archer
rich hill and michael walker for a
combined 12 for for actually less
they're getting three for one
and that's the way they operate and
these guys could be contributors so you
know they're going to be in the mix
somehow some way and small's talking
about the identity of a ball club
that's their identity they need all 26
players to contribute somehow some
someway
big cut and a miss from bobby dalbeck
took the league by storm last year eight
home runs in 23 games
a burst of strength
0 for 10 in the first series against
baltimore did not start the last two
games
but he was coming off a hot spring too
seven home runs he led the grapefruit
league
and carlos you know sometimes that's a
good thing and sometimes it doesn't mean
much
right i mean we were talking about the
fact that this is a long season and
maybe you get off to a good start it
doesn't mean much or you get off to a
bad start doesn't mean much but what
would we prefer we prefer to get off the
good starts
no doubt about it
it's a good game for dalbeck his second
hit of the day
and lois you've had some springs where
you were tearing it up and then you
start slow right and you've had some
springs where
you couldn't find it and all of a sudden
you found it just in time for opening
day
yes i have two two examples of that that
come immediately immediately to mine my
rookie season with the oakland a's this
is 2002 i'm showing my age
i had a horrible of spring training
horrible and then as soon as the bell
rang the lights were on and the season
started i went off i had an unbelievable
april and won rookie of the month in
april with seven home runs that's a
bullet yes it is off the bat of kevin
plawecki
and into right center field to aboard
for boston with one down in the eighth
and carlos we'll get back to in one sec
i just gotta sneak this in the
copyrighted telecast is presented by
authority of the office of the
commissioner of baseball and may not be
reproduced or re-transmitted in any form
and the accounts and descriptions of
this game may not be disseminated
without express written consent
that is signed sealed and delivered and
back to you
yes and another example of that was in
2013
uh 2012 actually i had a horrible spring
training and we are starting at home
against the yankees and joe madden told
me look it's going to be cece sabathia
on the mound you don't see him well
last time up
he broke your hand here's a double play
double play made we can come back hold
that thought hold that thought we'll get
back to it
colin mchugh cues up the double play
ball that he needs red sox don't need
much just
a strong ninth and they'll be on their
way
[Applause]
he'll go after that one and drive that
one high it's deep to left and that
ball's gone well there's number two he
didn't wait very long
don't you think the red sox have to make
sure he's in the lineup every day
that ball is hammered that's a high fly
ball twisting deep deep deep gone
berdugo strikes again
well that's the way to add on and get
some wiggle room deeper than the first
one also to the opposite field
there's a high fly ball driven deep to
right
gradual back to the pen
leaps up he caught it
he caught the ball
he took it back
tonight what a night
here's the pitch and a swing of the
drive down the right field deep back it
goes and it is gone opposite field home
run bobby dalback he's homered now in
five straight games that ties a red sox
record he didn't get it all but he's so
strong he jumped
well we are about to begin a grand
tradition
the youtube player of the game
looking at some candidates surrounded by
the trophy
i love the play button at the top there
we're gonna see that trophy in the hands
of one big man from this game it could
be
that guy jd martinez who is your choice
for player of the game if you're
watching right now
weigh in
bogarts martinez we'll get back to that
in a second because that one skips off
the wall and then it's bobbled in center
for a moment by renfro it turns into a
double by rosarina to lead off the ninth
again bogarts martinez ivaldi vazquez
it's got to be a red sock it's 9-1 in
the ninth vote now
winner holds the trophy
and chats with us after the game
choices john smoltz you start us off
they're all good ones you know i picked
bogarts before the game he went three
for three but it'd be hard to go against
baldy and what he was able to do
and dominate the rays for seven innings
uh so i'd say it's one of those two guys
you're not going to give me i'm going to
make you a ball like the choice of aldi
see that that's the i know that's the
grind in your head i went with bogarts
to start but i am a pitcher and he was
impressive he was very impressive so
ivaldi's your pick carlos what do you
think yeah i'm going to go with aldi i'm
going to go
yeah of course i picked jd martinez
earlier in the game but you you can't
argue with
the outstanding outing that uh uh just
had
got to give it to him
he recorded strikeouts
with all five of his pitches and you
rarely see that no he
look
he is so important to their rotation as
they get rodriguez back some point
during the season maybe sale
they've made nice moves under the radar
moves to fill in this rotation that i
guarantee you most people
are going to take them for granted
that's for devers
and the sacks are two abs away from a
sweep of the raise
i gotta finish my story oh yes quickly
yeah i know i gotta hurry hey so i
didn't have a good spring training and i
wasn't starting against cece sabathia
and as soon as i got to the ballpark
joe madden changed his mind and put me
in the lineup and i actually ended up
having one of the best games in my
career with a grand slam against so you
see a walk of
double off the wall against mariano
rivera and got off to a great april so
it doesn't matter spring training does
not matter
confirmed the andy diaz bounces out and
that was a nice hunch played by joe
madden back then for you carlos
there's two gone in the ninth
yeah that worked out
spring training was huge for me because
that's when i started learning how to
hit the knockdown shots because it's
usually windy and spring training
and uh we got a chance to play a lot of
golf and i felt like i could flight my
ball a lot better when the season
started
you know
to carry it through so spring training
was huge multiple
it worked out for you as well
that's excellent excellent
kevin padlow looking for his first
career hit as a big
leaguer i'm gonna say he gets it
yeah you think so youtube special
let's go he'd be able to roll back to it
and have it easily on youtube to play
back any time it's good dig me tape to
start off your career if he can do it
right here
that was a good pitch to do it with
[Laughter]
down the pipe he did walk back in the
seventh his first half out of the day
now i'm really locked in on this abc
more so there you go and i thought i
would be you know he never faced this
guy got his he's got the
kind of his eyes his own radar gun is in
his eyes and now he's seen a couple
pitches and he's looking for a mistake
to
put another point on the board called up
when kevin kiermeier was sent down
kiermeier on the injured list very
frustrating he said especially being
that it's early on in the season
quad tightness is the issue for the
reyes super center fielder
it would be hard for me to not sell out
on this pitch right here if i were up
the plate
3-1 lift clean and separate
give him something juicy
nope another walk
well the rays will respect that they
love that patience
not
we want to hit we wanted to hit scotty
i'm with you lois
there's something to be said about being
disciplined at the plate
but uh
you know just a quick story here in the
little league
teams where my my kids play you know
they're taking walks oh my gosh i i love
that you're on base but
swing the bat
swing the bat
that's what mike brasso does to left
open space and it's going to drop
in comes a rose arena
and the rays double their run total
mike brasso with an rbi knock
and padlow moves over to third
those are the ones that
eat at a pitcher's soul when you're
trying to get the last out you're
finishing a game you know you're going
to win
you just assumed he hit a rocket off the
wall but he had a big swing and
off the end of the bat
sure the mics picked up
part of what was being disgruntled at
you
didn't waste any time went after the
first pitch in his first at-bat and did
so again here and this time
he connects
there's a strike
google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
google cloud is the official cloud
technology of major league baseball
joseph odom
came in to replace francisco mejia
boston is one strike away this is an
impressive series from the red sox after
being swept by baltimore
[Applause]
tampa bay comes to town
and they have been dominated
this afternoon after a walk-off win last
night in 12.
red sox
commenting we have a rule never talk
about how fast the game is going we're a
little stitches
not superstitious just just a little
stitches
some great lines
by the red sox account today
providing some commentary for us
that is very creative
i can appreciate
the fireball review saying the comeback
has commenced well
win probability at this point 99 point
roll up the nines
[Laughter]
so you're saying there's a chance that's
right
2-2 to odom
did he go
yes he did
game over
red sox take the game red sox sweep the
series 9-2
all smiles after putting up double-digit
hits in all three games in this series
boston improves to three and three on
this young season and tampa bay drops to
two and four
some timely hitting didn't exactly hit a
ton of rockets but when it's going good
and you feel the mojo the red sox were
able to ride that
of course it's easier to ride when
you've got a stud on the mound who's
dictating opposite tempo by the team
he's facing in a baldi
two impressive performances today or in
this season so far for native aldi
today and on opening day against
baltimore this time he picks up the w
it is time
for the youtube postgame show presented
by fidelity
yes it is that time the youtube post
game show presented by fidelity scott
brown john smoltz carlos pena and alana
rizzo joining us again soon and the
youtube player of the game trophy will
be unveiled for the first time ever
hoping to be
a grand tradition
and we'll get that in the hands of the
winner according to you fans get to vote
on the poll winner and that also
dictates who we talk to at the end of
the game
9-2 boston takes it over tampa bay and
carlos hey we know how talented this
race team is they return a lot of the
same position players from last year
defense was elites last year they made
some mistakes on defense and they were
really shut down by native aldi and
company
yeah they had a tough time at the plate
you know baldy was throwing the high
fastball and working up that tops
for seamer and then throwing the off
speed but it is in the establishing the
fastball that all the other off speeds
become nasty and and he did a great job
of that
the hitters had to stay honest and when
you do that and you are you know that
there is a high speed coming your way
you tend to rush your swings which makes
you a more susceptible to chasing the
off-speed pitches
they struggle also defensively just not
the best showing uh for from the race
they're gonna have to just sweep this
one uh and flush it out the toilet and
get back ready to go tomorrow i have a
prize it's an air hug or an air high
five for john and for carlos because you
both correctly selected
the right answer for the youtube player
of the game the fans weighed in and they
agree with you nate ivaldi steals the
show despite the
offensive explosion again from boston
it's their starter their opening day
starter who shows up again in a big way
the youtube player of the game is native
aldi yeah early on he was uh probably a
little more erratic with his location
into this fastball but then once he
started throwing that spinning breaking
ball for a strike it locked everything
else in he climbed the ladder pitched up
and pitched on every side of the
quadrant as you mentioned earlier
scott he struck somebody out with every
one of his pitches and as as the
red sox rotation goes ivaldi will be
the reason
he was dominant in the game he was
dominant in the poll results red sox
fans weighing in and
giving ivaldi all they've got 45
he takes it over bogarts martinez and
vazquez and carlos from the hitter's
perspective when he's throwing five
strikeout pitches at you that's gonna be
tough to beat you
yeah you have to just pick one pick a
zone pick a speed because otherwise it's
just like walking into an ambush you
don't know what's coming your way so
your plan has to be on point the race
had a tough time defining what that plan
was and whatever they thought it was it
was not effective today and we have
mentioned that ivaldi is from alvin
texas same hometown as nolan ryan and
grew up idolizing him and he said you
can just see nolan ryan memorabilia
everywhere everyone talks about him but
here's a guy who comes from texas throws
really hard has a different game than
ryan but really has developed over many
years into a solid veteran when he's on
the mound he is really strong and he
showed that today well he has some of
the physical attributes that nolan ryan
have come from the waist down is so
strong his lower half strong look i
didn't mind working out with glavine and
maddox when we came in the weight room
it actually made me feel pretty good i
wouldn't want to work out with this guy
this guy is as strong as it gets and
when you look at the pitch mix and the
ability he has to get behind the
baseball that's the key when he gets
behind and on top of the baseball the
movement will be there and the hitter
has a nightmare to trying to
kind of decipher what pitch is coming at
him point zero zero three or whatever
the time a pitter has to make up his
mind on deciding whether a pitch is a
strike or not imagine what that's like
when you're facing a baldi he's on top
of you already he's six four five
whatever he is he's coming downhill with
a low three quarter and an up shoot type
fastball so when he's on as carlos has
said you you've got to figure out
what mistake can i hit and and wait for
a mistake because when he's on with the
quadrants that he can deliver
you better have a lightning quick
mechanically sound approach to the plate
because if you have a big swing he's
going to eat you up and for our youtube
creators if you have a question for
native aldi we have many for him and
he's coming up in just a moment the
youtube player of the game then let us
know in the commentary section right now
and here he is the youtube player of the
game joins us right now naty baldy nate
congratulations on the w there it is the
trophy hold it up big for us nate do you
know that this is the first time we're
ever doing this starting a new tradition
here for the game of the week live on
youtube so you're holding the hardware
what's it feel like how heavy how's it
look
it's heavy it's heavy it looks good yeah
proud to have it i like the design the
home plate and also the youtube play
button right at the top very legit yeah
hold it for the whole interview i like
it
display skills are perfect so and you
earn that nate so as you're checking it
out and you're gonna get to take that
home as you're working with that trophy
let us know how you earned that trophy
evaluate what you did today on the mound
yeah um you know plucky and i had a good
plan coming into the game we were able
to execute it uh it worked out well
defense was great behind me uh you know
we were able to put up some runs and
then once we started we you know we
didn't stop so it's always nice when you
can get a lot of run support during your
outings and
yeah i mean i felt really good out there
nate now i i know this is john smoltz i
know what your mindset is i love
watching you pitch bulldog on the mound
but i'm interested with this off season
mindset you had knowing there was a
short season followed by now a regular
season of of 162 games what did you do
differently or did did nothing matter to
you because this is what you've trained
your whole life to do as far as pitching
a lot of innings
yeah i mean honestly i didn't really
change too much um you know i got i got
going around the normal time that i
normally would and uh
you know i was fortunate enough to be
able to go to connor wong in the
offseason so i was able to get good
feedback on all my breaking balls all my
pitches um you know my main focus was
the splitter and then the curveball as
well and you know today i was able to
throw both of those pitches for strikes
uh really i was able to throw everything
tried to clean up the slider a little
bit more this offseason as well worked
on it in spring training felt like i had
the good bite that i needed for it today
and uh you know the raid is a really
good offensive team
uh in spring training they lit me up
with the fastball so try to learn from
those mistakes and uh keep them off
balance with y'all speed today and it
worked out for me
nathan i mean you just touched on you
working on your pitches and how you want
to improve your slider you want to
improve your cutter and and your split
and all that how much goes into your
strategy because we know your stuff is
devastating and just wipe out stuff but
if you had to put a percentage on what
you work on the most would it be
working on the pitches in particular or
more about how to utilize them together
as a sum of all parts
um for me it's working on a specific
pitch you know what i mean i can stand
by and listen to how we sequence and uh
you know how how to attack hitters
differently but for me it's getting that
consistent action for my splitter for my
slider for the cutter curveball's been
feeling really good the fastball is
usually there so i usually have pretty
good command with my fastball
so i mean it's really just
making sure that the pitches are
consistent a lot of the times the teams
they come out there and they'll try to
eliminate one pitch and usually i can
tell
what pitch that's going to be but i have
to be able to show them i'm going to be
able to throw it for strikes and then
throw it for balls as well so the
hitters are good there's so much uh you
know analytics that go into the game now
uh all the probabilities of what pitch
you're gonna throw at what time so i
gotta make sure to
not always rely so heavily on my
fastball but be able to rely on one of
those off speed pitches as well
nate you had mentioned this is alana
rizzo thanks for taking the time you had
mentioned that uh the fastball was
pretty much always there and that's what
hitters have come to expect from you
that that high velocity alex korres said
you never have to worry about that when
it comes to you
throw in the cutter today it seemed like
they were just getting a lot of weak
contact soft contact how important is it
for you to be able to just make a hitter
force a hitter and to have to you know
wait on something time one or the other
because they can't sit on both
yeah i mean it for me it starts with
strike one i gotta get strike one first
to keep them aggressive a lot of the
times if i fall behind an account you
know that's when i'm gonna get in
trouble um
you know i'm gonna have to rely on
something else because they're gonna be
waiting for the fastball so i feel like
that's where the cutter comes into play
you know it starts middle and then it
comes in on their hands and i get the
soft contact i was able to get uh you
know quite a few out today on the cutter
and then you know same with the splitter
as well the slider felt good too um so
it's really making sure i mix all my
pitches try not to get too predictable
out there and you know attack the zone
and when i'm ahead of the zone i usually
do pretty well nate here comes a
question from one of the youtube
creators in the commentary section from
moviegamingtv so and i know what one of
these answers is going to be nate how
does it feel to throw a 99 mile per hour
fastball and who were some of your
favorite pitchers to watch growing up
yeah i mean obviously it feels really
good being able to throw that hard and
then knowing that i have that in the
back pocket um
some of my favorite pitchers watching
growing up you know knowing ryan roger
clemens a lot of the astros guys
uh you know i really didn't watch too
much baseball when i was younger but
when i when i would it would be the
astros
that's a great one and also hey i know
this is a big day for the red sox fans
watching not only your start and how
great you were now in two starts but the
pitching gets even better tomorrow
because the pitching staff as a whole
because eduardo rodriguez makes his
return after sitting out last year with
myocarditis a result from covid19 so
what's he saying how excited is he and
also i heard he wanted to pitch today
for his birthday but they're like hey
cool it nate's got it it's his turn
we'll see you tomorrow
yeah i mean eddie never stops talking so
you know whatever he's talking you know
he's just nonstop so uh you know we're
obviously really excited to have him
back here on the mound you know he means
a lot to us means a lot to the rotation
the team everything he had to go through
last year was it was extremely tough to
watch and i think that's why we all take
covet over here so seriously because
we've got to witness it firsthand what
it can do to you um so having him back
out there on the mound tomorrow it's
gonna be great i know he wanted to go on
his birthday but he's getting a little
old now so he's gonna be careful yeah we
won't say the age on there nate you were
awesome today and great hanging with you
uh 28 there you go youtube player of the
game nate ivaldi hey you're the first
we're always going to look back today
first time we're giving that out show it
off that's nice i like it take it home
congratulations
thank you thanks for having me guys
appreciate it thanks nate that's native
alder youtube player of the game yeah it
looks good in person too
nate looks good obviously on the mound
but the trophy looks hey looks really
solid trophies uh
they're nice to have they're nice to
have i know you enjoy them too and
especially for someone so competitive
right if you heard that there was a
trophy like that just like we did in the
ninth inning wondering if kevin padlow
is gonna get his first knock if i told
you hey there's a special trophy for
this particular game it's just your
average regular season game i bet that
would stand out to you no doubt i'm
always trying to compete for whatever
the prize is i mean that's what uh
that's what fuels the engine
car i love you too
yeah like right now i'm competing for
one of those jerseys that that's mostly
said he has so many of them um you know
it's mostly if you could just please
sign one for me and dedicate it and i'll
give you my address i would greatly
appreciate that no problem we'll send it
to you carlos i also have some work for
you to do some more translating as we
listen in to a willy adams during this
game more players miked up
willy
hello
amazing carlos
they said your keyword i love that you
gotta love that he knew that we were on
of course and
uh he made sure that he just extended
his uh just saying hello you know i
appreciate that willie willie is one of
my favorites man hard worker and uh you
know i'm a big fan of his and everything
he does on the ball on the ball field
what did he say exactly for everyone
especially even for those who don't know
your catchphrase oh the placard of
course you go hey plaquette where you're
at where's he at he started like looking
up in the stands to see where we were at
i'm like oh buddy i'm i'm a little far
away right now but uh i'll make sure i
text him he's like hey man i'm in the
studio in disney right now so it's okay
yeah i'll catch you later yeah i'm
watching you guys and that's good
perspective too even though the rays
didn't play well not just today but in
this series they they know how good they
are this is baseball they're not
overreacting to a quote slow start at
two and four no they're not because they
have a great culture and that starts
with the management and it goes all the
way down to kevin cash and certainly
they understand the pieces of 162 games
and what each role is going to be on the
team you never want to go to a city and
get swept but i think what the rays have
been through and what they keep proving
everybody wrong i i am i'm amazed at
what this franchise has been able to do
the last five years
and so uh start of the season for them
is nothing more than a you know it just
is it is what it is they see the w's to
see the losses but they're going to run
into a bunch of them when they get
clicked when they get clicking because
they really are putting together a brand
new
somewhat brand new pitching staff so
that that takes a little time
offensively they are who they are but
the culture they've created is not going
to let them get the train off the tracks
yeah last year they had blake snell and
they had charlie morton and instead
their number two starters ryan yarbrough
who was on a roll and then things
skipped up a little bit lady baldi gets
the trophy he gets the high five
everything's going for the red sox
starter we'll step aside much more here
on the youtube post game show presented
by fidelity red sox win big and sweep
the series against the rays
[Music]
[Music]
it's blowing
almost at a 45 degree angle coming in
from the west
oh they lost momentum
come on you got this
and it is really coming down that tarp
not unrolling smoothly at all
darvish lost his glove
just added a new pitch to his repertoire
i think this is the throw my glove out
yeah look at that uh-huh still manages
to throw a strike
[Music]
that's a rocket foul down the line left
oh we got the bear just unbearable still
smiling
i can't bear to watch it
wow
look out yes
[Music]
yes it was
we're back with the youtube post game
show presented by fidelity scott brown
john smalls carlos pena and alana rizzo
will join us again shortly so the red
sox win big it's a statement series can
you call it that in the beginning of the
season more for the boston side based on
last year's performance last place
finish in the division and also like
alex cora said we're gonna hear it if we
have a slow start and we really pick
things up these last few days this is
all about the boston side this is about
uh the first three games not going the
way they want it at all and then you're
still at home and you're going to face a
team that came in that almost won the
world series it's a total statement and
of character builder for the club early
on for everybody else in baseball not as
much they're not dealing with the
narrative or the city and what happened
last year so i i can't oh you know i
can't overstate enough that clubhouse
feels good about rallying last night
taking care of business today but more
importantly they're three and three
they're starting the season they start
feeling like oh okay we're in good shape
everything's good yeah and you start to
see what makes this red red sox team
special potentially is the offense i
mean that's the part of their game that
shined last year top five in the
american league and run scored so carlos
based on what you've seen in this first
week without overreacting
can you confirm or deny that the red sox
might be better than they appeared
heading into the season
you know i think i've been guilty of
leaving the red sox out of the
conversation in the american league east
but yes after watching them uh today and
the way they went about their business
at the plate you know i'm not sure we we
should do that you know this is a team
that needs to be
recognized of course there are some
questions on the pitching staff but
you've already they're at the top and
then the smallz was talking about it
when as he goes the entire staff's gonna
go rodriguez is about to come back as
well and if those two are doing uh what
they're supposed to be doing they're
gonna give a lot of quality starts and a
lot of opportunity for the red talks to
be right where they want to be so i
would put the red sox back in the mix
even though i am honest i did leave them
out early in the year looking at them on
paper the offense is still there and if
the pitchers do their job and just
contribute they don't have to have a
monster years just do what they're
supposed to do
they will be
in the hunt there in the american league
east they head to baltimore after this
it's the home opener for the orioles
tomorrow they have three games coming up
against the orioles they started against
the orioles oh and three but they pick
up three wins against tampa bay the
latest one looked like this
xander bogarts with devers on second
bogarts golfs it to center and that's
gonna fall in front of margot
rounding third is devers and he's gonna
score
xander bogarts evens this game up at one
with the rbi knock he's just too good
against left-handed pitchers right now
he's just too good in general he's not a
one of those simple approach doesn't
miss his pitch
but he has really had success against
left-handed pitching 10 home runs in his
first four seasons in the big leagues
and then a career-high 23 all of a
sudden in 2019.
2-1 offering is blasted
[Applause]
christian vasquez lives up to his new
name and goes long
on cue scotty on cube we'll see what
that pitch was but it seemed like it was
something up and in it might have been
that cutter and christian vasquez was
ready for it he got ready early enough
to be able to get his swinging
and a healthy ride in the dugout it's
the new celebration you hit a homer
you ride the roller coaster hit list
this afternoon
but off to a 10-23 start
two homers five doubles
and he gives that ball a ride
deep left will it stay fair
and it's high off the wall
and it'll score a couple runs for boston
flowecki comes in so does hernandez
and jd martinez has himself a run
scoring double it's 4-1 boston
it was slightly early on this pitch
right here but he was able to keep that
barrel
in the zone for long enough
and his teammate is the first player in
red sox history with an extra base hit
his first six games of the season
starting to show a little bit of their
old self when they were a
crooked number machine meaning they
could put up a crooked number in any one
of those nine innings
and now drops one into shallow left and
that'll score another one for boston
jd come on down it's 6-1
hunter renfro for two today
broke his back
serves one up here for adonis
and the throw skips away
and bogarts comes home it's 7-1
and here comes another it's vasquez
racing around they go
key mishap
from tampa bay on defense and it opens
this one up
yeah it really did blew the game wide
open for boston and then this is how it
finished up
taylor gets odom
it's done
red sox win red sox sweep they take all
three look at that little punch there
too john
little baseball chuck
you unhappy nope
well his team's thrilled 9-2 winners as
they improve to three and three on the
season alana rizzo at the ballpark
hanging out with us all day alana how's
it going out there
oh it's good nice to wrap things up here
from fenway and certainly if you are a
red sox fan you were pleased with not
only what you saw today scotty but what
the red sox were able to do over the
course of the last three games it's been
well documented of course that they
started the season at home the worst
that they have since
1948 going 0-3 they answered the call
able to get the sweep evening up the
series season series three and three and
an opportunity to get back at those
orioles as they start a three-game set
with the o's in baltimore tomorrow
afternoon as far as the rays are
concerned they leave here perhaps with a
bit of a sour taste in their mouth after
ryan yarbrough had such a good start in
his first outing of the year a little
bit more shaky today as far as the
mechanics and the delivery and the
results were concerned but the red sox
fans have a lot to look forward to the
boston red sox as far as a team
certainly very likely uh happy with
their performance today guys yeah thank
you alana and it's alex cora back with
this team after of course sitting out
last year and he's got to be pleased i
agree with what they just put together
against the defending american league
champs we have more coming at you on the
youtube post game show presented by
fidelity in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
the first time in his major league
career in his
125th game todd frazier is going to
pitch his best pitching at the age of
12. and swanson hits one out to center
field and mariznick back to the warning
track and fraser has gotten one long out
look at the cash in here
and he got the knuckle ball for a strike
struck him out my gosh
how about that
players who fool around with knuckle
balls on the side but not too many throw
them in games when they get a chance
that's drilled to center and on comes
mariznick and a one two three inning for
the knuckleballer 1-1
[Applause]
this in the air out to right field adele
was in
angling back he gets there wow and he
just
put it right over the fence
like a center in volleyball
he just pushed it right over
he shot that over the wall from about
five feet away
we're back it's the youtube post game
show presented by fidelity scope around
john smoltz and carlos pena with you and
the red sox take it over the tampa bay
rays they sweep tampa bay in this series
very impressive performance and and
sports gaming universe also says let's
do this again soon everyone i agree more
on that coming up in just a moment we'll
tell you what the next game looks like
but carlos christian vasquez homered
last night against diego castillo to
save the day for boston homers again
today absolutely punish that baseball
how impressive does the red sox catcher
i know he was dh today but the red sox
catcher look in terms of what he's able
to bring to this team at the plate very
different from how he looked in his
first few years as a big leaguer
timing is the number one most important
element of hitting and this is something
that he's been working on on you know
throughout the last couple seasons he's
working look how early he gets ready to
be able to get that healthy swing at the
baseball you want to make sure that you
get as many of those as possible you see
the extra velocity
104.9 miles per hour off of his barrel
that ball was absolutely smoked now
doesn't mean you swing harder it just
means you get ready earlier and you're
getting cadence with the pitch i think
he's gotten a lot
smarter when it comes to that and a lot
more effective when it comes to making
sure that his timing is on point for the
pitcher uh that he's facing every single
on a nightly basis and he was for sure
on time today yeah he's rounded into an
all-around performer for boston he was
known right away for his pitch framing
his game calling a guy that you'd
probably love to throw to yeah i think
any time you see a player and i saw a
slew of my uh teammates every once in a
while you see the light or the click or
the mechanics click in to where it
unleashed something that maybe wasn't
there before and he's got that
confidence now it's changed his career
you know instead of a part-time catcher
who's known for his defense he now has a
dual weapon in the offense that he's
going to be in there majority of the
time so good for him and his career and
the trajectory it was taken because
sometimes things take a while for
players to you know convey or get out
and for whatever reason to the carlos
point he's been able to do that and the
timing seems like it times it looks like
there's the beach balls coming in and a
beach ball is going out so
good for him and the red sox and
especially when you're a catcher there's
a lot to learn as you work your way up
through the system the minor leagues and
then into the majors to learn your
pictures he did that he accomplished
that first and then came his hitting
prowess so congrats to vodkas and the
red sox for the win we do this a lot
this year thursday april 22nd angels and
astros coverage begins 7 30 eastern time
i'll be with you on the pregame show and
on the call you can see matt baskergen
mark gubza jeff plum and brett dolan
it's the mlb game of the week live on
youtube
on april 22nd we'll have over 20 games
coming at you this season it's all free
it's on youtube and we'll of course be
bringing that beautiful trophy with us
around the country for the player of the
game carlos we'll see that thing
everywhere same thing and native aldi
really showed it off well but he also
really showed off his stuff this
afternoon for the boston red sox let's
push it forward though you have the
angels taking on the astros in the
american league west when we talk over
reaction city in the first week of the
season
some might say hey the angels and astros
look like the best teams in the division
while the a's have been struggling out
of the stretch what do you think of the
entire al west so far in this first week
of the season
well interesting this is not the way we
scripted it you know i had the a's uh
getting off the gates hot it was
obviously a long season but the astros
are nothing to sniff at even the angels
were looking at the fact that they are
also candidates to be in the mix they
certainly have that lineup to do so so
it it'll be interesting to see how the
long season plays out as we've alluded
to in this program
look your weaknesses will be exposed in
a long year 162 games but getting off to
a good start
it can only help and and these guys have
done exactly that
it helps when you're healthy too john
when you have shohei otani on the mound
right now for the angels the a's
suffered the loss of trevor rosenthal to
an injury for now who's supposed to be a
big deal out of the bullpen for them so
yes that's just your early season
overreaction momentum but how do you
size up the division well the one thing
i think when we talk about fans and we
talked about you know the noises and
sounds of the game well the astros are
going to deal with that this year but
the astros seem to have some form of
that chip that still remains on their
shoulder to prove why they're a very
good baseball team that what happened a
couple years ago is in the past and i
think the way they handled it and the
way that you know dusty baker has
brought this team it's a young team but
their offense both teams to me
offensively doesn't have as many
concerns it's can either team
find enough pitching to get through the
162. you know fran beer for me is is a
stud that unfortunately got an injury
yeah foreign
for the astros but i just think you know
the astros have that internal engine
ticking
and the fire burning to prove some
things still this year
two years removed that is going to serve
them well for the for the american
league they're balancing that chip
they're keeping it on their shoulders
still yeah i'm not
i play with the chip on my shoulder a
lot of players can play with the chip on
the shoulder and serve them well some it
advances them to a point where it does a
detriment to them and i think the the
just the
the core young players that are still
there
they want to prove why
they're some of the best offensive you
know they could be one of the best
offensive teams in the american league
star power in that game so get ready for
it april 22nd it's the astros the angels
it's altuve it's correa it's trout it's
ohtani and the names go on and on random
so that's it for this game at fenway
park and the youtube post game show
presented by fidelity again next one
coming at you april 22nd astros and
angels coverage begins with our pre-game
show at 7 30 eastern for the hall of
famer john smoltz big strong carlos pena
the great ilana rizzo and our entire
superstar crew i'm scott braun logging
out for now thank you so much for
watching the mlb game of the week live
on youtube presented by fidelity we'll
see you for the next one okay
oh
you